ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTEE TO ORDER --
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE
GONNA START AS A COMMITTEE
SUBCOMMITTEE [inaudible]
SUBCOMMITTEE -- THEIR TOTAL
FOURTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
SIX OF THOSE ITEMS ARE CAN ON
CONSENT THOSE BILLS INCLUDE ITEM
NUMBER ONE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE ITEM NUMBER SIX ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN I WOULD NEVER TAN AND ITEM
NUMBER -- ELEVEN IS THERE ANY --
ANYBODY WISHING TO PULL ANYTHING
OFF THE A CONSENT.
COUNTY.
SO OKAY SO WE'LL MOVE ALONG.
THE OTHER TWO I'LL BET YOU WOULD.
SO WITH THAT -- WE'RE GONNA
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND
WE'RE GOING TO ASK -- SENATOR
MCGUIRE TO COME FORWARD AT THIS
TIME TO PRESENT SB [inaudible]
SIX SEVENTY WARNING SENATOR
[inaudible]
THEY MORNING [inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR I WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK IN
YOUR STAFF'S WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
I CENTER NIELSEN WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING WITH US IS CURRENTLY
PRESENTING THREE BILLS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY NET IF YOU'VE
HEARD BUT THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF A MEETING GOING ON OVER THERE --
SO HE WILL BE HERE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE -- OR THE HEAVY LIFTING
ON A THEIR YEAH -- OR HE'LL BE
HERE TOMORROW NIGHT SO -- AND AS
A MEMBER GALLAGHER WHO'S GONNA
ALSO PLAN IN PRESENTING TODAY
WITH US.
IS IN COMMITTEES I DO APOLOGIZE
AND ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO CHAIRMAN DOT. FOR HIS
PARTNERSHIP -- NOT JUST ON THIS
BILL BUT THROUGHOUT THE NORTH
BAY FIRES HI CHAIRMAN DODD HAS
BEEN A TENACIOUS ADVOCATE HE'S
BEEN FIGHTING FOR THE FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED FOR THE
SURVIVORS.
IN JUST ONE TAKE MOMENT SAY
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK
AND ALL SHE'S A FIRE PREVENTION
RESPONSE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LIKE WHY SEVEN THANK
YOU.
MEMBERS IN MISTER CHAIR THE
NIGHT OF OCTOBER A CHANGE THE
LIVES OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR EVER.
WHETHER YOU'RE ONE OF THE TEN
WANT ONE OF YOU WHETHER YOU WERE
ONE OF THE ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EVACUATED. ONE OF THE SIX
THOUSAND WHO LOST THEIR HOME.
ONE OF THE THOUSANDS WHO FLED IN
THE MIDDLE IN NINETY THROUGH THE
FLAMES OR ONE OF THE DOZENS.
IT DOESN'T TO OFF LOAD LOS LED
ONES DUE TO A FIRE.
YOUR LIFE SHOULD NOT GO IN VAIN.
IMAGINE BEING IN A LIFE
THREATENING EMERGENCY PICKING UP
YOUR PHONE TO CALL 911- IN
HAVING NO SERVICE OR DIAL TONE.
OR BEING DEAD IS SLEEPING NEVER
RECEIVING EMERGENCY ALERT TO LET
YOU KNOW FLAMES CLOSE IN IN IN
ABOUT TWO ANGLE FOR HOME.
UNFORTUNATELY THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE FACED WITH THE
REALITY SEVERAL TIMES A YEAR NOW.
IN THESE REAL WORLD SCENARIOS
ARE INCREASING TO THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF CALIFORNIA'S WHILE IN
FIRES.
IN AN EMERGENCY OR CATASTROPHIC
SITUATION LACK OF ACCESS TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE PUBLIC
ALERTS AND WARNINGS BUT LIVES AT
RISK.
SB SIX SEVENTY IS A SIMPLE STEP
TO MITIGATE THE RISKS DURING
TIMES OF TOTAL CRISIS INFONET
DIGITS.
BY REQUIRING THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE REPORTS OF NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE OUTAGES OR OUTAGES
AFFECTING ALERT IN MORNING
TELETECH KNOWLEDGE SHE'S TO THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
IN REAL TIME.
THIS SEEMS LIKE IT SHOULD
ALREADY BE HAPPENING NOW BUT
IT'S NOT.
IT'S COMMONSENSE APPROACH WILL
ENSURE COORDINATION BETWEEN
STATE AND LOCAL EMERGENCY
OFFICIALS AND TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES.
SB SIX SEVEN PROVIDE EMERGENCY
OFFICIALS WITH REAL TIME DATA
REAL TIME DATA.
IN THE CRUCIAL INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO BE TO KEEP OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE.
THE FEDERAL TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION ONLY REQUIRES
REPORTING OUTAGES THAT LAST
THIRTY MINUTES.
AND HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO AFFECT
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND USER
MINUTES.
BREAKING THIS DOWN UNDER THIS
THRESHOLD IT WOULD TAKE TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
HAVE ANY NOW DID YOU THE LAST
NINETY SIXTEEN MINUTES BEFORE
THE THRESHOLD FOR REPORTING TO
THE FCC IS ACTUALLY HIT.
AND THEN PROVIDERS ARE GIVEN
ANOTHER HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MINUTES TO NOTIFY THE FCC.
BUT HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
WELL THAT IS A DELAYED RESPONSE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHO IS
NOT RESPONDING DIRECTLY HERE IN
THIS STATE.
THEY THEN SEND THOSE NOTICES
THAT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION.
BECAUSE THEY SHARE ALL
COMPONENTS OF NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE.
AND IF YOU SEE IS NOT DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN THE FIGHT WHEN IT
COMES TO NATURAL DISASTERS.
SO THE NOTIFICATION OF A NINE
ONE ONE OUT EACH. FOR NOW IS AN
FX EMERGENCY ALERTS HAPPEN
SOMETIMES DAYS AFTER THE ACTUAL
PARTIES OCCURS NOT REAL TIME
WHEN TO GIVE YOU TWO EXAMPLES.
DURING THE CAMPFIRE.
WHICH THE SHERIFF WILL BE
SPEAKING ABOUT IN JUST A BIT
MORE GRATEFUL THAT HE'S HERE.
THE CAMPFIRE BEGAN AT
APPROXIMATELY SIX THIRTY THREE
AM ON NOVEMBER EIGHTH.
THE CPUC RECEIVED A NOTIFICATION
FROM THE FCC OF THE OUTAGE. FIVE
HOURS LATER.
AT TWELVE OH ONE PM AFTER
THOUSANDS OF HOMES HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED.
THE TUBS FIRE IN SANTA ROSA.
IT BEGAN APPROXIMATELY NINE
FORTY THREE PM ON OCTOBER EIGHTH.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO SEE IF
YOU SEE RECEIVE THEIR
NOTIFICATION FROM THE FCC OVER
SIX HOURS LATER AT FOUR TWELVE
AM THE NEXT MORNING.
AND IN THAT TIME.
THOUSANDS OF HOMES HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED IN THE FLAMES.
BY THAT TIME THE TUBS FIRE HAD
BURNED INTO CENTRAL SANTA ROSA.
IN CALLAWAY YES NEVER RECEIVED A
FORMAL NOTIFICATION.
CURRENTLY ONE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES GO DOWN AFFECTING NINE
ONE ONE SERVICE OR THE ABILITY
FOR EMERGENCY OFFICIALS A CENTER
EMERGENCY ALERTS.
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO REPORT REAL TIME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE LOCATION
OF THE OUTAGE HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE AFFECTED AND
WHEN THE ESTIMATED TIME FOR
REPAIR EASE.
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT AFFORD TO BE
WITHOUT THE MOST UP TO DATE
INFORMATION DURING TIMES OF
DISASTER.
SB SIX SEVENTY WOULD REQUIRE
PROVIDERS OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES TO PROVIDE NOTIFICATION
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES WHENEVER THERE IS A
NINE ONE ONE SERVICE OUTAGE OR
ANY OUTAGE AFFECTING EMERGENCY
WARNING CAPABILITIES.
WITHIN SIXTY MINUTES OF THAT
OUTAGE STARTING.
CALLOW YES WITHIN BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR NOTIFYING THE AFFECTED LOCAL
COUNTY -- YES AND THIS WOULD
ENSURE THAT ALL NECESSARY MERCY
FISHEL'S ARE GETTING THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO GO TO
KEEP RESIDENTS SAFE.
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO NOTIFY CAL
WE **** WITHIN SIXTY MINUTES AND
THE FOLLOWING TYPES OF
INFORMATION WHEN AN OUTAGE
OCCURS THE DESCRIPTION OF THE
ESTIMATED AREA AFFECTED.
THE APPROXIMATE NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS AFFECTED THE ESTIMATED
TIME TO RESTORE THE OUTAGE IN A
CONTACT PERSON THAT CAO YES CAN
REACH OUT FOR FURTHER UPDATES.
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE ALREADY
DO WHEN IT COMES TO ELECTRIC
OUTAGES IN THE STATE.
ON INDEED HERE MISTER CHAIR.
AND SAY THAT SB SIX SEVENTY WILL
ENSURE OUR STATE AND LOCAL
EMERGENCY OFFICIALS HAVE RESPOND
EARNERS AND FIRST RESPONDERS AT
THE CRUCIAL INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO RESPOND WHEN THOSE EXTRA
MINUTES CAN SAVE LIVES.
WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL THAT WE
HAVE THE CHIEF OF CENTER AS A
FIRE HERE TODAY NUMBER CAN I CAN
I HAVE YOU INTRODUCED THE THEM
IN ONE SECOND WE HAVE A QUORUM
IS DO AS WE LIKE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
IN THE CLERK PLEASE -- CALL THE
ROLL.
DODD.
YOUR SITE HERE WILK PRESIDENT OF
CARE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA THERE ARE TWENTY HERE
FORGES BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE CHIANG HERE CHIANG
HERE GALGIANI GALGIANI HERE
GLAZER.
HILL.
HILL HERE WEST SO JOHN'S
[inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO HERE RUBIO.
RUBIO HERE WINNER.
NIELSEN HERE.
TO NIELSEN.
YEAH NOTHING HERE THANK YOU OKAY
WHILE WE'RE AT IT THEN ON A ROLL
HERE WE'RE GOING -- TO ASK FOR A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT -- ITEMS.
IN THE THERE ARE -- AS I SAID
BEFORE. SIX ITEMS ANYBODY
WISHING TO PULL ANYTHING OFF
THIS CONTENT ON SEEING NONE
KUGLER CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
DOT.
YES.
I WILL HI WILK AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D FORGES BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI CHANGE.
CHIANG HI GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL.
HELLO FIVE WEST SO.
JONES [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
REVIEW AYE WIENER.
OKAY WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS RIGHT THANK YOU
CENTER PLEASE PROCEED NO THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR AGAIN
WE HAVE A FIRE CHIEF GEISINGER
WITH THE CITY SANTA ROSA WE ARE
SURE OF HOW MANY HERE.
SHARE FOR BUTTE COUNTY AND THAT
WORKS FOR THE CHAIR WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE -- YET
ANOTHER PARTNER.
WE HAVE HAD SENATOR NIELSEN WHO
IS BEING INSTRUMENTAL ON THE
RECOVERY -- WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CAMPFIRE IN WORKING WITH SINGER
DIED MYSELF IN IF IT WORKS FOR
THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE BETTER
TURNED OVER TO THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM?
YOU CAN.
PLEASE PROCEED CENTER NIELSEN.
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO
PLEASURE WORKING.
WITH CENTER TO ACQUIRE.
WE ARE SIMPLY PLACED.
SENATE IS DEALING WITH
[inaudible]
INCREDIBLE TRAGEDIES.
AS HAS THE CHAIRMAN AS WELL.
AND WE DEAL WITH THESE TRAGEDIES.
THAT PUTS A REAL FACE ON THERE'S
NOTHING ABSTRACT.
IT'S VERY REAL.
WE'VE DEALT VERY PERSONALLY-CONTINUE TO DEAL VERY PERSONALLY
WITH INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED.
AND WHEN YOU DO NOT HAVE.
THE ON OPPORTUNITY THERE WAS
SOME FAILURE IN OUR SYSTEM OF
COMMUNICATION THE NINE ONE ONE
OR WHATEVER.
LIVES ARE AT RISK.
IN THE TWO GENTLEMAN HERE WITH
US TODAY.
LOOKED AT IN THE AYE VERY
PERSONAL.
AND I WANT TO SAY [inaudible]
VERY PERSONALLY [inaudible]
THE BURDEN [inaudible]
PLACED UPON [inaudible]
OUR PROFESSIONALS.
THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
THIS IS NOT RELATED TO THE FIRE
BUT RATHER TO A POTENTIAL FLOOD
DID [inaudible]
REQUIRED.
SHARE OF HOLLY TO MAKE A
DECISION.
REGARDING THE LIVES OF A HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THAT WOULD DOWN RIVER FROM THE
OROVILLE DAM.
AND I WAS TALKING TO SHARE A
PHONY ELEVEN O'CLOCK AT NIGHT.
DOES THIS FAILURE WAS DEVELOPING.
HE SAID JIM I'M GETTING
CONFLICTING REPORTS FROM
OFFICIALS HERE.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT I'M GOING TO
HAVE TO DO.
THIS WAS AS TO ORDERING THE
EVACUATION.
OF A HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IN SUCH AS A TRUST I PUT INTO
INDIVIDUALS LIKE THIS TO
PROFESSIONS HERE WITH US TODAY.
I SAID CORY.
HERE'S WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY TO
YOU.
YOU MAKE YOUR DECISION.
I WON'T BE BEHIND YOU.
I WON'T BE BESIDE YOU.
I WILL BE IN FRONT OF THE AND
WE'LL GET IT DONE.
ANY RESPONDED ANY DID THE RIGHT
THING.
I AM FAMILIAR WITH.
SANTA ROSA HAVING REPRESENTED
FOR MANY YEARS [inaudible]
NEVER.
THE FIRES INFLICTED [inaudible]
SONOMA COUNTY.
ENCROACH INTO THE URBAN AREA.
THE NORTH SANTA ROSA.
BUT I KNOW HOW [inaudible]
THE LOS.
AND MANY OF MY FRIENDS WERE
DEVASTATED BY THE LOSS AND ARE
STILL SUFFERING.
ALL THESE YEARS LATER FROM THE
LOSS AND I REPRESENTED
[inaudible]
LAKE COUNTY.
AND MY COLLEAGUE HERE WHO'S
PRESENTING THIS BILL.
THIS HAD TO LIVE ABOUT TWO
CYCLES OF FIRES IN HIS CAREER
THUS FAR JUST IN LAKE COUNTY.
BILLS LIKE THIS ARE NEEDED
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
[inaudible] TO ENSURE.
THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT.
THE MAXIMUM UNFETTERED
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE NOTIFIED.
AND TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ACTION ON
THEIR PART. TO PROTECT THEIR OWN
LIVES AND PROPERTY.
WELL THESE OTHER PUBLIC
OFFICIALS.
PUT THEIR LIVES [inaudible]
AND PROPERTY.
ON THE LINE.
AND ONE LAST OBSERVATION.
CHAIR PHONY IS OPINED.
AS THE CHIEF WILL.
TO THE IRONY OF HIM.
ORDERING PEOPLE.
THE NOMINATION PEOPLE TO
EVACUATE.
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY ORDERING
THE PEOPLE UNDER HIS EMPLOY. TO
PUT THEMSELVES.
IN HARM'S WAY.
THAT'S YOUR BURDEN.
WE'VE GOT TO GIVE THEM EVERY BIT
OF HELP WE CAN'T.
AND THE CITIZENS THAT WE
REPRESENT.
EVERY BIT OF OPPORTUNITY.
WE CAN GET THEM. TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK SENATOR.
JOINT CHIEFS.
MORNING.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TONY GOES ON THE FIRE CHIEF FOR
THE CITY SANTA ROSA.
THE RECENT FIRES OF SONOMA NAPA
OF INTER COUNTIES HAVE AMONG THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE IN STTE
HISTORY.
THE DISASTERS HAVE SHOWN THAT
THE MERCY TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEMS NEED TO BE IMPROVED BOTH
FOR THE WRIST RESIDENTS.
AND THE FIRST RESPONDERS.
WHAT THE TUBS AND THE NUNS IN
CINEMA COUNTY THE ATLAS NAPA
REDWOOD IN MENDOCINO COUNTY THE
THOMAS INVERT WINTER?
AND LAST YEAR THE CAR IN THE
CAMP FIRE.
THESE FIRES ARE BURNING ADD ADD
ON CONTROL REYES AND WE'VE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE.
NOT TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
PERSPECTIVE THE TUBS FIRE THAT
IMPACTED THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA
STARTED IN AND THE COUNTY OF
NAPA.
WITHIN FOUR HOURS OF BURN.
TWELVE MILES AND LANDED IN THE
HEART OF THE CITY SANTA ROSA
FOUR HOURS.
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT NINETY SIXTY
FOR THE SAME FOOTPRINT NAY
HANLEY FIRE TOOK FOUR DAYS TO
GET THERE -- AND AND THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A MISNOMER IT WAS
MORE LIKE EIGHTEEN HOURS ONCE A
WIN SHIFTED BUT IT TOOK EIGHTEEN
HOURS IT TOOK FOUR HOURS -- FOR
OUR FIRE.
DURING THAT TIME WE LOST THREE
THOUSAND HOMES SANTA ROSA WITH
THE COUNTY -- AND SANTA ROSA
THERE WERE SIX THOUSAND HOMES
DESTROYED.
AND TWENTY FOUR LIVES WERE TAKEN
FROM US.
EARLY WARNING IN IS VITAL SO
WEAKENED WHEN WE KNOW ABOUT THE
SITUATIONS WE CAN GET THE WORD
OUT AS QUICK AS WE CAN AND WE
CAN HELP PEOPLE EVACUATE.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT NIGHT IN
SANTA ROSA FROM SIX O'CLOCK IN
THE EVENING UNTIL MIDNIGHT -- WE
HAD TEN REPORTED STRUCTURE FIRES
AND TWENTY REPORTED VEGETATION
FIRES JUST IN THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA.
SO WE WERE EXTREMELY BUSY --
WALL THE FIRE -- THE THE TUBS
FIRE STARTED AT NINE FORTY FIVE
IN ANOTHER COUNTY AND DIDN'T
EVEN HIT US UNTIL ONE IN THE
MORNING.
SO THE SITUATIONAL AWARENESS WAS
VERY DIFFICULT TO GRASP IN TERMS
OF WHAT WAS COMING TOWARDS US
BECAUSE WE WERE SO BUSY.
IN OUR OWN RIGHT.
SB SIX SEVENTY WOULD REQUIRE
PROVIDERS TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES TO NOTIFY CAL -- YES
WHENEVER THERE'S A NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE OUTAGE OR ANY OUTAGE
AFFECTING OR MERCY WARNING
CAPABILITIES WITHIN SIXTY
MINUTES.
OF THE OUTAGE. SIXTY MINUTES IS
A GREAT STARTING POINT BUT I
THINK IT NEEDS TO BE SOONER --
BUT SIXTY MINUTES IS A GREAT
STARTING POINT.
KALLUS WITHIN LET THE LOCAL
MERCY PERSONAL.
KNOW ABOUT THESE OUTAGES.
WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL NECESSARY
MERCY OFFICIALS ARE GETTING THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO KEEP
THE RESIDENTS SAVE TO ALLOW US --
TO LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEY ARE
IN DANGER.
THE FIRST FEW HOURS OF OUR FIRE
THE TUBS AND ALSO THE NINES WE
LOST MORE THAN SEVENTY CELL
TOWERS WITHIN THE FIRST FEW
HOURS OF THE FIRE.
ONCE YOU LOSE A A CELL TOWER YOU
LOSE COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
RESIDENTS YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT.
WE NEED TO HAVE THE EARLY
NOTIFICATION SO WE CAN GET THE
PROPER NOTIFICATIONS OUT --
IT'LL ALSO GIVE US BETTER
SITUATIONAL RON AWARENESS WHICH
WILL HAPPEN AROUND US -- IN IT.
WILL.
HELP US INFORMED ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT THAT WERE TRYING TO PROTECT.
SB SIX SEVENTY WILSHIRE THAT OUR
STATE LOCAL MERCY OFFICIALS AND
RESPOND HERS HAVE THE CRUCIAL
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO RESPOND
WHEN THOSE EXTRA MINUTES COULD
SAVE LIVES.
THE BILL.
SB SIX SEVENTY IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT MEASURES TO COME
BEFORE THE LEGISLATION THIS.
AT THE SESSION THE CITY'S
GENERAL AND MYSELF SUPPORT THIS
BILL WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD MORNING CENTERED ON MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME -- BUT ALSO LIKE TO
THANK US IN REGARDS FOR NELSON
FOR INVITING ME -- IS YOU KNOW
MY NAME IS COREY HONEY AND I'M
THE SHERIFF OF BI<c.cyan> COUNTY.</c>
I'M ALSO THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE STATE NINE ONE ONE ADVISORY
BOARD.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS
WELL AS CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
AS YOU KNOW MY COUNTY IS NO
STRANGER TO HAVING TO NOTIFY
PEOPLE OF HI IMPENDING.
DANGEROUS CONDITIONS -- AT A
MOMENT'S NOTICE.
CENTER NIELSEN SPOKE OF THE ORAL
DAM SPILLWAYS INCIDENT -- AND
THEN AGAIN -- MOST RECENTLY --
THE CAMPFIRE.
IN BETWEEN THAT THOUGH OTHER
OTHER FIRES THAT WE HAD TO
UTILIZE.
OUR MERCY MASSED ON VACATION
SYSTEM RELYING HEAVILY POINT
WHERE SHE DID SHE TELL YOU CASES
SYSTEM. TO ALERT OUR CITIZENS TO
THE THREAT THAT WAS COMING THEIR
WAY.
A CAMPFIRE IS YOU KNOW HAS BEEN
DETERMINED AT THIS POINT AND I
HOPE IT STAYS THAT WAY THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE FIRE IN HISTORY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IT CONSUMES SOME EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND STRUCTURES REGRETTABLY
RESULTED IN THE DEATH OF EIGHTY
FIVE CITIZENS.
RATE.
ULTIMATELY CONSUMED HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND ACRES.
OVER THE COURSE OF TIME.
PUBLIC SAFETY HAS BECOME A VERY
RELIANT UPON THE MERCY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM. TO
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR CITIZENS
ABOUT THREATS THAT THEY ARE
FACING.
AS WELL AS THEM COMMUNICATE WITH
US ABOUT THREATS THE TO THE CITY.
QUITE FRANKLY IT IS THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH CITIZENS.
AND ALTHOUGH -- IT IS.
BECAUSE THE TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGICALLY BASED SYSTEM --
AND CERTAINLY.
HAS.
THE POTENTIAL FOR GOING DOWN --
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE -- TO
UNDERSTAND WHEN THAT HAPPENS AND
THEN ADJUST OUR RESPONSE
ACCORDINGLY.
AS YOU KNOW -- SENATE BILL SIX
SEVENTY I WOULD REQUIRE -- THE
OUTAGE TO BE -- THE THE THE THE
THE PROVIDERS FOR TO A NOTIFY
CALLOW YES AND THEN THE SHERIFF
AND LOCAL MERCY MANAGEMENT.
OF THE OUTAGE WITHIN ONE HOUR OF
THEM DISCOVERED.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT THING IT WOULD HELP US
UNDERSTAND THE LANDSCAPE THAT
WERE OPERATING IN AND IT JUST
OUR APPROACH TO NOTIFYING
EVACUATING PEOPLE.
MUCH MUCH MORE EFFECTIVELY AND
MUCH MORE QUICKLY.
I KNOW DURING THE COURSE OF OUR
PRELIMINARY AN ONGOING
EVALUATION OF THE RESPONSE IN
OUR EFFORT TO NOTIFY PEOPLE.
THE PRELIMINARY INFORMATION WE
HAVE AT THIS POINT IS THAT -- WE
SENT OUT -- OVER TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND ALERTS THROUGH OUR
MERCY MASS NOTIFICATION SYSTEM --
MANY OF THEM GOING -- TO PEOPLE
WITH CELL PHONES.
UNFORTUNATELY IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE WAS A FAILURE RATE OF
ABOUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND AND THAT
BEGAN AROUND NINE O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING.
BUT AS YOU HEARD A MOMENT AGO --
WE WEREN'T NOTIFIED OF THE
OUTAGE UNTIL AROUND.
TWELVE I WOULD HOPE THAT HAD WE
BEEN ARMED WITH THE KNOWLEDGE
EARLIER IN THE DAY -- WE COULD
HAVE ADJUSTED OUR APPROACH -- TO
COMMUNICATING WITH HE COMMUNITY
pTHAT HOPEFULLY WOULD HAVE
REACHED PEOPLE I THINK THAT THIS
BILL WILL CERTAINLY GO A LONG
WAY TOWARDS DOING THAT.
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO
STREAMLINE.
THE COMMUNICATION OF CRITICAL
INFORMATION TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ON THE GROUND.
WHO ARE MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT
HOW -- TO NOTIFY PEOPLE OF
DANGERS AND TO ALERT THEM TO THE
RIGHT COURSE OF ACTION I THINK
IS IMPORTANT.
SB SIX SEVENTY WOULD CERTAINLY
DO THAT WHICH IS WHY I'M IN
SUPPORT OF IT WHICH I THINK --
IS WHY CALIFORNIA SURE
SUFFICIENT SUPPORT OF IT AND I
WOULD ASK THE U. S. SUPPORT AS
WELL.
THANK YOU SHERIFF -- ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE US
STATE YOUR NAME ADD YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND WHAT DO YOU
SUPPORT OR NOT.
THE MORNING TRACY RHYME ROLE
COUNTY REPRESENTS A CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MORNING CHAIR -- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RUBBER TO GO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE U. CALIFORNIA
CITIES ONE I THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE --
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT THANKS.
MR MEMBERS DAVID YOUNG ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR IMPORTANT
BILL FOR THE CITY SANTA ROSA
WEEK STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING CAROLING I'VE EVER
THE NAPA AND COUNT A NAPA AND
SONOMA COUNTY BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS THINK THE AUTHOR IN
THE SURE FOR BEING HERE ASK FOR
EITHER TODAY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MUCH LOBBY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I JULIE NON OWSKI BOBBY HALF OF
THE FIRE DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIAN THE FIRE CHIEFS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FIRE
CHIEFS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADELINE COOPER ON
BEHALF OF MARIN COUNTY AND
SUPPORT.
MORE MATURE MEMBERS BERNIE
ROSCOE THE CABLE ASSOCIATION WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE AMENDED AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE ARE LOOKING
FOR IS A STRONGER COORDINATION
WITH -- YES ACTUALLY THERE IS
SOME PRECEDENT WITH -- YES
WORKING WITH THE LANDS THE OLD
COPPER NETWORK FOLKS ON DOING
SOMEPROTOCOLS.
FOR EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS ARE
WE RIGHT NOW ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF DOING THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
OURSELVES FOR THE CABLE INSIST
INSTITUTION -- MEMBERS SO OUR
HOPE IS THAT AT SOME POINT WITH
MISPRINT WHY WE HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS REQUIRE IS THAT WE
CAN SORT OF FORMALIZED THAT
RELATIONSHIP.
SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION VERY TIMELY WE SEE
THIS AS A COMPLIMENT TO YOUR
LEGISLATION LASHER EIGHT THREE
THREE WHICH WAS SIGNIFICANT I
THINK THAT WAS FAR MORE
DIFFICULT AND GETTING TRAINING
TO A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND WENT
TO ISSUE ALERTS.
IT DOES A LARGE CAN GET OUT
EARLIER OVER OUR NETWORKS BEFORE
THEY BURNED OUT.
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE MOST
TIMELY IMPACT THAT YOU CAN HAVE
SO A LOT OF THIS INFORMATION IS
VERY VALUABLE FOR BUILDING OUR
NETWORKS OUT LATER ON BUT I
THINK THERE IS IF YOU LOOK AT
THE DIFFERENT COUNTIES THAT HAVE
HANDLED THOSE ALERTS DIFFERENTLY --
ONE OF THE COUNTIES LAKE COUNTY
ACTUALLY WAS VERY STRATEGIC AND
INNER ALERTS UP VERY EARLY AND
HAD A FORMER POSITIVE IMPACT.
BUT WE DO SEE THIS THIS BILL AS
A COMPLEMENT TO THAT BILL AND WE
DO WANT TO WORK FOR THE CENTER
AND GET THAT ACCOMPLISHED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON PROCEED TIA WHERE THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY TRADE
ASSOCIATION WE TOO ARE WORKING
WITH MISTER MCGUIRE AND YES SORT
OF SORT OF IT'S A THREE
DIMENSIONAL CHESS -- AS WERE
ATTEMPTING TO TO FIGURE OUT THE
BEST WAY TO DO THIS WE ALSO WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH MR REQUIRE ON
SB EIGHT THIRTY THREE LAST YEAR.
WHICH THE INTENT FOR WHICH TO
BRING THE WIRELESS EMERGENCY
ALERT SYSTEM WHICH IS BY FAR THE
BEST.
WAY TO NOTIFY THE MOST PEOPLE IN
ALL THESE FIRES A TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN DO THAT IN A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY -- AS WE'RE
WORKING NOW WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE BUILD IN THE REQUISITE
FLEXIBILITY -- THAT ALSO
RECOGNIZES TECHNOLOGY
DIFFERENCES AMONGST A MONTH THE
FIRST TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS WE HAVE THE ABSOLUTE
US MODE.
GROUPS RESPECT FOR UP FOR THE
FIRST RESPONDERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOLKS APPEAR AND
HOPE WE CAN KIND OF ALL WORK
TOGETHER TO TO GET TO A GOOD
PLACE AND I THINK WE WILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING THAT ALL TURNED BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
BILLY WISHING TO COMMENT
[inaudible]
CENTER GALGIANI [inaudible]
PLEASE.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION -- TO
APPROVE -- THE BILL OF THE
MOTION AND WILL BE DO PASSED TO
JUDICIARY.
APPROPRIATIONS BROKE SKEWS ME
APPROPRIATIONS I'M SORRY.
CLOSING COMMENTS HE'S GONNA SAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR ALL
YOUR WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE WE COULD NOT BE DOING THIS
WITHOUT YOU WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO CENTER NIELSEN FOR HIS
INCREDIBLE PARTNERSHIP AND
CONTINUE.
TO WORK SO DILIGENTLY ON THIS
ISSUE SENATOR GALLAGHER AS WELL
CENTER STERN AND WILL BE ADDING
SENATOR HILL SINCE WE TAKE
AMENDMENTS IN CENTER STONE.
ON TO THIS BILL IS WELL AND WE
WILL CONTINUE OUR DIALOGUE --
WITH TELECOM CABLE AND NOW YOU
HAVE MY COMMITMENT ON THAT.
THANK YOU NEED -- UP.
HAVE LONG HISTORY WITH THE YEAH
THE FIRE CHIEF HERE IN THE NORTH
BAY FIRES BUT JEFF I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A TOUR OF
PARADISE THE OTHER DAY AND
YOU'LL BE ABLE OR BUILD JUST.
KIND OF TO GET THE LOGISTICS OF
BOTH THE YEAH THE SPILL WAY
SITUATION AND THE FIRES AND I
CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE.
WHAT YOU MUST BEEN IN IN YOUR
STEAM?
HAVE YOU HAD TO GO THROUGH IN IN
IN IN THOSE TWO EVENTS SO I
REALLY MY HAT GOES OFF TO A JOB
WELL DONE.
SO WITH THAT CAN OCCUR CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
FILE ITEM TWELVE SB SIX SEVENTY
MOTIONS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DOT.
I THOUGHT I WILK [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL.
HELLO FIVE WESTERN [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
THE HOLDER OPEN [inaudible] SIX
THE BILL HAS -- SIX VOTE TO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
OKAY NOW WHAT WE'RE GONNA MOVED
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB ONE SIXTY
CENTER JACKSON
[inaudible]
MORNING CENTER.
I AM HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SB
ONE SIXTY A BILL THAT DIRECTS
COUNTIES TO INTEGRATE CULTURAL
COMPETENCE.
INTO THE NEXT PHASE AN UPDATE OF
THEIR COUNTY EMERGENCY PLANS.
I KNOW THAT THE PRIOR THE BILL
ALSO ADDRESSES WHAT WE DO IN
CASES OF EMERGENCY.
AND I KNOW THAT THE CHAIR AS
WELL AS OTHER MEMBERS HERE.
HAVE OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
EXPERIENCE THESE DRAMATIC AND
LIFE THREATENING CIRCUMSTANCES
IN THEIR OWN DISTRICTS.
WE ALL KNOW IT IS THE INHERENT
RESPONSIBILITY OF GOVERNMENT AT
ALL LEVELS TO PROTECT LIFE AND
PROPERTY.
DURING EMERGENCIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CARRY OUT THIS
RESPONSIBILITY BY PLANNING FOR
NATURAL AND HUMAN CAUSED
DISASTERS.
AND GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S VAST
DIVERSITY IT IS UP TO LOCAL
PLANNERS TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE VARIOUS NEEDS OF THEIR
COUNTIES THEIR COMMUNITIES --
EQUALLY DIVERSE AS THEY ARE.
THE LEGISLATURE'S RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS PARTICULAR
ASPECT OF LOCAL EMERGENCY
PLANNING FIRST.
WITH THE AB TWENTY THREE ELEVEN
BACK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BROWN WHICH
REQUIRES COUNTIES TO INTEGRATE
PLANNING FOR THE ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS.
RESIDENTS THAT LIVE IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS NEED AS THEY DO
THEIR NEXT UPDATE OF THEIR
COUNTY EMERGENCY PLAN.
LAST YEAR AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
MONN BASED UPON THE THOMAS FIRE
IN OUR ASSURE DISTRICT --
ADDRESS THE LACK OF ADEQUATE
LANGUAGE TRANSLATION SERVICES
DISPLAYED DURING BOTH THE ATLAS
AND THOMAS FIRES OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AMONG OTHERS.
AND THIS BILL REQUIRES CAL --
YES TO DEVELOP A LIBRARY OF
EMERGENCY RELATED TERMS AND
PHRASES FOR COUNTIES TO HAVE AS
REFERENCE WHEN DEVELOPING
TRANSLATED VERSIONS OF THEIR
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS.
AS AN EXAMPLE DURING THE THOMAS
FIRE WHICH BURNED FOR FORTY DAYS
IN MY DISTRICT.
A DISTANCE OF ABOUT FORTY FIVE
MILES THE TRANSLATION TO OUR
APPROXIMATELY 40% OF SPANISH
SPEAKING COMMUNITY WAS DONE
THROUGH A GOOGLE APP AND
REFERRED TO THE FIRE IS THE HAIR
BRUSH FIRE.
OBVIOUSLY A LITTLE MISLEADING
FOR A FIRE THAT BURNED ALMOST
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES.
AND YET FOR SPANISH SPEAKING
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T ACTUALLY LOOK
OUT THE WINDOW AND SEE THIS
HORRIFIC FIRE BURNING.
THEY WERE TOLD IT WAS A HAIR
BRUSH FIRE.
SO WE REALIZE THAT.
WE HAVE GOT TO DO MORE AND WHILE
THESE EFFORTS HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION MORE WORK NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN ORDER TO FULLY INTEGRATE.
THE NEEDS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
INTO OUR COUNTY EMERGENCY
PLANNING.
THE POINT WAS MADE EVIDENT
INDEED DURING A HEARING THAT THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT HELD IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHILE I
WAS ITS CHAIR.
WHICH EXAMINED HOW RECENT
LEGISLATION HAS INDEED IMPROVED
EMERGENCY ALERTS IN CALIFORNIA
THE AHA MOMENT THOUGH FOR THIS
BILL CAME WHEN WITNESSES
DESCRIBE HOW FOR NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING COMMUNITIES.
COUNTIES HAVING A STAFF MEMBER
PROFICIENT IN THE LANGUAGE OF A
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY IS SIMPLY
NOT ENOUGH. TO HAVE AN EFFECTIVE
STREAM OF COMMUNICATION WITH
THEM.
IT ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE COUNTY
HAVE COMPLEMENTARY COMPREHENSIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE CULTURAL
AND SOCIAL DYNAMICS OF THAT
COMMUNITY IT'S CULTURAL
COMPETENCE SO THE QUESTION IS IF
PEOPLE GIVEN NOTICE.
WERE THEY GIVEN NOTICE SO WHAT
ARE THEY GIVEN NOTICE ON THERE
SOME COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO CERTAIN TYPES OF
PRINCIPALLY WIRELESS
COMMUNICATIONS WHO ARE THEY
LIKELY TO LISTEN.
TO HOW ARE THEY LIKELY TO REACT
WHO ARE THE PEOPLE MOST LIKELY
TO BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE IN
HELPING THESE COMMUNITIES DO
WHAT IS NECESSARY TO BE KEPT TO
BE SAFE.
AND AVOID THE DANGERS OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES SO THIS COMP A
CONCEPT OF CULTURAL COMPETENCE.
REALLY TRANSCENDS LANGUAGE
BARRIERS TO ALSO APPLY TO
ENGLISH SPEAKING COMMUNITIES
WERE A LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OF
THE SOCIO ECONOMICS THE DIVERSE
GENDER EXPRESSIONS AND
IDENTITIES EDUCATION LEVELS H.
RELIGIOUS AND GEOGRAPHIC
DIFFERENCES.
OF THE DIFFERENT POCKETS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES LITERALLY GO
UNADDRESSED IN COUNTY EMERGENCY
PLANNING.
THIS MEASURE SEEKS TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE BY REQUIRING COUNTY
GOVERNMENT OFFICES OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO IMPLEMENT CULTURAL
COMPETENCE INTO THE NET STOP
DATE OF THEIR EMERGENCY PLANS.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
DIVERSE CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC
NEEDS OF ALL OUR RESIDENTS ARE
ADDRESSED WE ARE WORKING
TOGETHER WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES
IN ORDER TO NARROW THE BILL SO
THAT WE REACH THAT LEVEL.
OF COMPETENCE -- IN A WAY THAT
IS MOST COST EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY THE GOAL IS TO SAVE
LIVES TO SAY PROPERTY AND TO
MAKE SURE ALL OF THE PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE PROTECTED.
AND WITH THAT I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY PEDRO ROCK ROLL BLISS A
COMMUNITY LEADER WITH COST BASED
IN VENTURA COUNTY.
AND ARMY ROBEL A WOMEN'S POLICY
INSTITUTE FELLOW [inaudible]
PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS PEDRO LISTEN
I'M A COMMUNITY LEADER WITH
COSTS THE CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE
UNITED FOR A SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY.
I AM A SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON SB.
ONE SIXTEEN I LIVE IN SANTA
PAULA THE CITY WITH THE THOMAS
FIRE BROKE OUT IN DECEMBER.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THIS IS A
CIRCLE A LOT OF MEDIA ATTENTION
BY BEING ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BUYERS IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY BUT
THE DAMAGE THE SENATE JUST BE ON
THE FIRE.
THE LACK OF INFORMATION
ASSISTANCE AND WARNINGS RECEIVED
BY THE COMMUNITY WAS MINIMAL AND
ALL HONESTLY TRULY FRIGHTENING.
RECREATIONAL OURS THROUGHOUT THE
CITY WERE MANDATED HOWEVER MOST
FAMILY STAYED IN THEIR HOMES AS
BY THE FIRES BURNING SO CLOSE TO
THEM.
IN MY CASE MY FAMILY DID NOT
RECEIVE ANY NOTICES FROM THE
COUNTY ABOUT THE FIRE.
EVACUATION ROADS OR EVEN REESE
WAS LIKE THE SHELTERS.
THE REALITY WAS THAT THE ONLY
WAY PEOPLE UPDATED WITH THE FIRE
WAS A WORD OF MOUTH NEIGHBOR TO
NEIGHBOR.
NOBODY KNEW WHERE TO GO WHAT TO
DO OR HOW TO REACT DURING THIS
DISASTER.
SADLY YOU MOTHER WAS MORE
NOTIFICATION GO INTO THE
COMMUNITY THERE WAS NO POWER
INTERNET OR EVEN SELL SERVICE
DURING THE PEAK OF A DISASTER.
PERSONAL HELP SENT TO OUR BLOCKS
ARE NEIGHBORHOODS OR COMMUNITIES
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT I KNOW ALSO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO A CELL
PHONE SMARTPHONE WHICH MEANT
THEY WERE LEFT OUT OF THE FEW
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS THAT
WORSE IN TOWN.
IF CULTURE THE NEEDS OF
COMMUNITIES WERE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION IN THE PLANNING OF
EMERGENCIES OR COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS.
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE IN
THE PLANNING PROCESS OUR
COMMUNITY ARE COUNTIES WILL BE
BETTER PREPARED TO AID AND SERVE
ALL COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
DURING DISASTERS AND EMERGENCIES.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE THE
ACTIONS OF POWER NEIGHBORHOODS
FUNCTION AND CLEAN YOU KNOW WHAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE WE SHOULD HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENGAGE
EMERGENCY PLANNING IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR LOCAL --
YES OF UP MORE OF US EMERGENCY
PLAN. TO MAKE SURE IT NEEDS OF
LIBERAL COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
ARE NOT FORGOTTEN.
OUR COMMITTEES ARE THE FIRST TO
SUFFER FROM THESE DISASTERS AND
THE LAST RECEIVE HELP.
THIS BILL WILL.
THIS BILL WILL GIVE OUR COUNTIES
THE GUIDANCE THEY NEED TO ENSURE
THE SAFETY OF US MANY
INDIVIDUALS POSSIBLE.
COMMUNITY WHERE'S THE PLAYING
WASHINGTON THREE COUNTIES
EMERGENCY PLANS AND ALLOW THE
OFFICES OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO CREATE
AND EXECUTE BETTER PLAN FUTURE
EMERGENCIES.
HOW ALSO THE COUNTY EXPECTED TO
KNOW THE NEEDS OF COMMUNITIES OF
THEY ARE NEVER ENGAGED WITH ONE
ANOTHER?
I SINCERELY HOPE WHICH ALTHOUGH
YES ON THIS BILL AND ARE JUST
REGULAR COUNTY EMERGENCY PLANS
TO INCLUDE THE NEEDS OF
CULTURALLY DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELL DONE.
GREAT THE MORNING CHAIR DIED IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS AMIR OF ALL SENIOR
POLICY RESEARCHER WITH THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK OR
A PEN.
WE SECURE BY MAIL JUSTICE FOR
ASIAN AMERICAN IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE COMMUNITIES.
WE ARE PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
VIRAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
COSPONSORED THIS BILL ALONG SIDE
THE WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON SB
ONE SIXTY FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS.
FIRST DISASTER PREPAREDNESS IS
IMMINENT.
FROM INTENSE STORMS OF CAUSE
MUDSLIDES AND FLOODING TO RECORD
BREAKING WILD FIRES AND HEAT
WAVES.
RECENT EVENTS MAKE CLEAR THE
DESTRUCTIVE IMPACTS OF CLUB
DISASTERS FUELED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THESE THREATS WILL ONLY
INTENSIFY RESULTING IN MAJOR
HEALTH AND LIVELIHOOD
CONSEQUENCES.
THEREFORE IT IS IMPERATIVE TO
STRENGTHEN EMERGENCY PROTOCOLS
NOW.
BY INSURING COUNTIES HAVE THE
ASSISTANCE AND RESOURCES TO DO
SO [inaudible]
SECOND.
THIS BILL PRIORITIZES THE NEEDS
OF CULTURALLY DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES.
STORIES LIKE THE ONE JUST SHARED
AMPLIFY THE IMPORTANCE OF
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS THAT
CENTERS ARE STATES DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES.
WHEN DISASTERS HIT?
EXISTING INEQUALITIES WORSEN.
THIS MEANS THAT THOSE MOST
IMPACTED ARE CONSISTENTLY THE
PEOPLE WITH THE LEAST RESOURCES
TO RESPOND WHICH INCLUDES LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES HOMELESS
FOLKS THE ELDERLY YOUTH THE
DISABLED LGBTQ FOLKS AND OUTDOOR
WORKERS.
FINALLY COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
CREATES AN OPENING TO DIRECTLY
HEAR FROM RESIDENTS ON THE FRONT
LINES OF DISASTERS.
IT IS CLEAR THAT EACH COUNTY
NEEDS A LOCALIZED APPROACH TO
EMERGENCIES.
PUBLIC MEETINGS COORDINATED
ALONGSIDE TRUSTED PARTNERS AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS CAN SHARE
ISSUES AND IDEAS SPECIFIC TO
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
THIS COULD INCLUDE ASSISTING
COUNTIES WITH PLANNING AFFECTED
EVACUATION ROUTES OR DESIGNING
SAFE INCLUSIVE EMERGENCY
SHELTERS.
IT ALSO PROMOTES BROADER
AWARENESS ABOUT RESOURCES AND
PROTOCOLS ALREADY IN PLACE TO
RESPOND.
COLLABORATION BETWEEN EMERGENCY
PLANNERS RESPONDER IS AND
RESIDENTS ALL OF WHOM ARE
EXPERTS IS CRITICAL TO
ACCOUNTING FOR UNIQUE COMMUNITY
NEEDS.
ULTIMATELY PROTECTING THE SAFETY
OF EVERYONE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I WILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MARKETS CUTTHROAT THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MORNING THE END OF ASK IS --
POLICY MANAGER FOR HELPING HIM
TO DISCIPLINE STRONG.
SUPPORTER OF THE BILL AND CO
SPONSORS BUT ALSO IN A REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR A MENTAL HEALTH
COALITION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ERIN RODRIGUEZ WITH
THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MORE SECONDS ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS DIDN'T
AGNEW SO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IAN FORSYTH THE CITY OF
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF THE
STREAMS IN SUPPORT OF HI MY
NAME'S TINA ROBINSON WITH A PEN
BUT WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PAULINA
TORE AS WITH THE CENTER AND
REYES POWER POVERTY IN THE RAM
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI GOOD MORNING SYLVIA OUT OF ON
THE WITH COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS A SEE A
MARK HAS BEEN TURNED TWENTY
RESIDENT AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MORGAN CANYON WITH BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
I AM SOVIET GM OAKLAND RESIDENTS
SUPPORT THE BILL.
IS THERE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION I WOULD THINK NOT --
RETURN -- TO THE COMMITTEE
CENTER GALGIANI.
AND I'M I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
I'M WONDERING WHAT SOMEBODY'S
EXAMPLES MIGHT LOOK LIKE OF OF
COMPLYING WITH THIS BILL I AM
I'M SEARCHING MY MIND ABOUT IT
AND WONDERING IF.
WHAT YOU ENVISION IS PERHAPS
HAVING -- COORDINATED COMMUNITY
MEETINGS WHERE THE ORGANIZERS
ARE ACTUALLY REACHING OUT. TO
THE DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND ASKING THEM TO
PARTICIPTE.
SO THAT.
A BROAD NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
AND GROUPS IN THE COMMUNITY HAVE
THE ABILITY.
TO TALK TO OTHERS IN THEIR IN
THEIR ORGANIZATIONS ABOUT THE
THE THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
HOPING TO DO WE ARE ALSO MINDFUL
THAT WE ARE PROBABLY GOING TO BE
WORKING WITHIN.
A LIMITED FISCAL FRAMEWORK -- SO
WE WANT TO MAXIMIZE THEIR
PARTICIPATION.
BUT AT WHILE MAXIMIZING IT
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE AS
SENSITIVE AS WE CAN BE. TWO OF
THE COMMUNITY NEEDS AS WELL SO
HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE A COMMUNITY%
RESPONSE I KNOW BECAUSE AS AN
ORGANIZATION IN MY DISTRICT DID.
VERY WELL REPRESENTS -- THE
NEEDS IN THE VALUES OF THE
LATINO AND SPANISH SPEAKING
COMMUNITIES IN THE DISTRICT WE
ALSO ENVISION THAT -- FOR IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE
THERE ARE LARGE POPULATIONS OF
MYSTICAL OR I KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
DISTRICT TO HAVE.
FUN I CAN NEVER REMEMBER THE
NAME OF BUT OF THE THE GALI IS
SAID TO HER.
THE THE FILIPINO REPRESENTATION
OF OF FOLKS AND THAT WE ENVISION.
AREAS IN EACH COMMUNITY WHERE
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT -- A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF PEOPLE --
WITH DIFFERENT CULTURAL --
ISSUES AND THE LANGUAGE ISSUES
THAT THEY WILL BE PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION SO THAT WHEN WE DO
THE OUTRAGE FOR EXAMPLE -- THE
SOME COMMUNITIES THE CHURCH IS
THE CENTER OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CHURCHES ARE FIRST TO KNOW MAKE
SURE THAT.
IF POSSIBLE WE CAN HAVE.
EMERGENCY -- LOCATION SET UP
WITHIN A CHURCH COMMUNITY
KNOWING THAT PEOPLE ARE MORE
DISPOSED TO A PARTICULAR AREA
SOME ARE LESS LIKELY FOR EXAMPLE
TO GO TO A SHELTER.
IN AN AREA THEY DON'T KNOW OR
ARE IT WOULD RATHER STAY CLOSER
TO HOME AND TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS SO THAT WHEN THESE
EMERGENCY ROOM.
EMERGENCIES ARISE WE HAVE THE
BEST WAY TO LET THE TO GIVE THEM
AS EARLY NOTICE AS POSSIBLE.
AND INSTRUCTIONS AND DIRECTIONS
AS TO WHERE THEY CAN GO WHERE
THEY'RE COMFORTABLE WHERE THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE OPTIONS ARE
IN RIGHT NOW FRANKLY WE JUST WE
DON'T HAVE THAT.
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE IN
MIND OKAY I AM I ENVISION IS
SOMEWHAT LIKE WHEN AS AN ORGAN
IT AWHILE BUT A GOVERNMENT
ENTITY GOES INTO A COMMUNITY
WITH IT. TOO WITH REGARD TWENTY
I ARE FOR EXAMPLE IN A LIST WHO
THEY REACHED OUT TO WHICH WHICH
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMMUNITIES AND THEN THEY SORT
OF TRACK THAT THROUGH THE
PROCESS IT SOUNDS LIKE.
THAT SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR BUT THEN YOU'RE
TAKING AT THE EXTRA STEPS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WHEN THERE'S
EMERGENCY PLANNING.
FOR WHEN AN EVENT ACTUALLY
OCCURS THAT YOU'RE TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION WHAT IT WOULD BE A
CHURCH.
RIGHT WE WANT TO GET THAT INPUT
FROM THE VARIOUS COMMUNITIES
SAYS WHAT IS MOST CULTURALLY.
COMFORTABLE ACCEPTABLE
RESPONSIVE -- ONE SIZE DOESN'T
FIT ALL WE'VE DISCOVERED AND
THAT'S THE GOAL HERE IS TO TRY
TO ACCOMMODATE AS BEST WE CAN
THE NEEDS OF ALL.
A DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES WITHIN
THE STATE.
THANK YOU AND I'D BE HAPPY TO CO
AUTHOR THE BILL WITH YOU THANK
YOU.
SO CAN I ACCEPT THE MOTION FROM
YOU -- CENTER GALGIANI YES YOU
CAN I'M OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO CLAIM THINK THESE WITNESSES
WERE IS ARTICULATE AND EXPRESS
THE NEED AND I THINK WE'VE ALL
HAD THESE EXPERIENCES WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY SO WITH THAT I'D
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR -- THIS --
THIS ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH CLARK --
CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM TO SB
ONE SIXTY MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DODD HI DODD HI
WILK [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL.
HELLO HI WES SO [inaudible]
JONES.
SO BY WEST SO I THINK YOU
[inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO HI.
RUBIO AYE WIENER. FIVE TWO ZERO
HOLDEN THE BILL HAS FIVE WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU MISTER CARE AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
MRS HERE HURTS.
MY SENSE HERE SO WE'LL CENTER
HUESO ITEM NINE FIVE ITEM NINE
SB.
FIVE FIVE EIGHT THE MORNING Q.
THANK YOU MISTER GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME -- TO PRESENT AS P..
FIVE FIVE EIGHT A BILL THAT
WOULD CREATE A COMMISSION OF
CALIFORNIA MEXICO AFFAIRS.
THE IDEA OF THIS BILL IS TO
ACTIVATE THE VERY DIVERSE
CITIZENRY OF CAL OF CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE THAT ARE ENGAGING IN
EDUCATION AND BUSINESS AND EVERY
EVERY LEVEL OF ADVOCACY.
AND CALIFORNIA'S VERY DIVERSE AS
A SOCIETY.
THE IDEA IS TO CREATE.
A COMMISSION THAT WILL INTERFACE
WITH OTHER OTHR LEADERS AND
OTHER -- BUSINESS PEOPLE IN
MEXICO -- FOR THE PURPOSES OF
BRINGING OR STATES CLOSER CLOSER-TOGETHER AND USING THESE
COMMISSIONS -- SO VEHICLE TO
DEVELOP.
POLICY AT THE CITIZEN LEVEL --
TO BRING TO THE LEGISLATURE
EVENTUALLY THAT WOULD BE THE
GOAL. TO TO HELP GET.
A TALENTED PEOPLE IN OUR STATE
TO HELP US SOLVE OUR PROBLEMS
AND AND CREATE BRIDGES AND OF
HELP US GROW OUR RELATIONSHIP.
WITH WITH MEXICO THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT.
THE CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER
REGION IS HOME TO SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE.
AND GENERATES TWENTY FOUR POINT
THREE BILLION IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY -- THIS UP BORDER IS
DYNAMIC -- MANY THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE BORDER EVERY
DAY -- LOTS OF THINGS ARE
HAPPENING -- TOURISM -- EXCHANGE
CULTURAL EXCHANGES WE ALSO ON AN
ECONOMIC LEVEL ARE PRODUCING
THINGS TOGETHER.
OFTENTIMES A PRODUCT THAT --
BEGINS ITS PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA GOES INTO MEXICO. TO
BE FURTHER -- DEVELOPED AND
COMES BACK TO CALIFORNIA TO BE
FINISHED.
THERE ARE MANY.
WAYS THAT WERE WORKING TOGETHER.
AND TOGETHER OUR STATE EXPORTS
TO MEXICO -- BUT JUST OUR STATE
TO EXPORT TO LOAN TOTAL TWENTY
SIX POINT. EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
AND THAT HAS BEEN GROWING.
I EVERY SUCCESS OF YOUR AS
CALIFORNIA'S HAVE BECOME A
LITTLE MORE -- INTERESTED IN IN
COMMUNICATING AND CREATING
BRIDGES WITH MEXICO THAT NUMBER
IS GOING UP.
TODAY TRADE WITH MEXICO POST.
TRADE WITH MEXICO SUPPORTS FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S A LOT OF JOBS.
BUT WE CAN DO A LOT MORE.
AND THE IDEA IS TO CREATE -- OF
A STRONGER OF FABRIC IN OUR
SOCIETY THAT INTERFACES WITH
MEXICO THAT CREATES MORE JOBS
THAT -- BRINGS US CLOSER
TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT ALLOWS
FOR OUR MUTUAL PROSPERITY I
OFTEN TELL PEOPLE AS CALIFORNIAN
AND MEXICO'S.
ECONOMY GROWS IT BENEFITS US
BOTH IT IT LEADS TO MORE JOBS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER.
AND I THINK THAT'S WE SHOULD
WHICH WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON
HELPING TO IMPROVE OUR ARC --
NOT ONLY OUR OWN ECONOMY BUT BY
IMPROVING OUR ECONOMY WE CAN
HELP -- IMPROVE MEXICO'S ECONOMY
IN OTHER LATIN AMERICAN
COUNTRIES FOR THAT FOR THAT
MATTER AS WELL -- WE ARE ARE FAR
BEHIND OTHER STATES IN IN OUR
PARK PER CAPITA INVOLVEMENT WITH
MEXICO AND JUST WHAT I THINK WE
HAVE A LOT MORE OFFER
[inaudible]
TEXAS EXPORTS.
EXPORTS WITH MEXICO OUT DID OURS
BY SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S JUST A IN ADDITION TO
WHAT WE'VE DONE.
ESTABLISHING A COMMISSION ON
CALIFORNIA MEXICO AFFAIRS CAN
HELP US ACTIVATE THE FULL SET OF
BENEFITS THAT COME WITH A STRONG
CALIFORNIA MEXICO PARTNERSHIP
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY FOR THIS.
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
TURN BACK TO US.
THE COMMITTEE SENATOR -- RUBIO.
THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION ANYBODY ELSE --
I JUST HAD A COMMENT WE USED TO
HAVE THE OFFICE OF TRADE AND
COMMERCE AND DO YOU ENVISION --
GETTING DELVING INTO THAT AREA
SOME ABOUT WHAT ARE OUR TRADE --
ISSUES ARE AND HOW THAT'S
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE.
IN AND MY HOPE IS THAT THOSE
ISSUES WOULD BE ADDRESSED.
THAT BY PUTTING PEOPLE IN THERE
WITH AN INTEREST IN THAT AREA
THAT THE BUT I I WOULD LIKE --
THE A COMMISSION TO DEAL WITH
KIND OF A BROAD RANGE OF ISSUES
OFTENTIMES.
THERE ARE SOME SAFETY ISSUES
OTHERS TRANSPORTATION ISSUES
ENVIRONMENTAL.
THEIR BUSINESS ISSUES AND
EDUCATION AS WELL CULTURAL AND I
THINK WE ESTABLISH A A VERY
DIVERSE.
BOARD I THINK ALL ALL THAT GROUP.
WILL TAKE AN INTEREST IN THOSE
ISSUES AND MOVE AN AGENDA THAT
THAT WILL DEAL WITH.
THE ISSUE OF THE DAY AS IT DEALS
WITH OUR RELATIONS WITH MEXICO
BUT ESTABLISH IN THE COMMISSION
WILL SEND A VERY CLEAR MESSAGE
THE CALIFORNIA.
HIS IS A SEIZE MEXICO AS AN ALLY
AS A FRIEND.
AND WE WANT TO SORT OUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT DEAL WITH OUR
OUR RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES THERE
ARE MANY.
AND I REMEMBER WHEN I FIRST GOT
ELECTED TO THE COUNCIL THAT WAS
SO ONE REPRESENTING JUST THE
BORDER -- IN THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
CAME TO ME AND SAID THESE ARE
THE DEAL THE ISSUES WE'RE
DEALING WITH AT THIS MOMENT.
IT WAS A REALLY REALLY LONG LIST
AND MOST OF THOSE ISSUES ARE
DIFFICULT.
BUT I THINK MOST OF THE I WOULD
I WOULD SAY THAT IT CAUGHT ME BY
SURPRISE AND AND AND THOSE THOSE
CHALLENGES WILL WILL CONTINUE.
BUT THERE IS A NOTHING STOPPING
OF FROM SOME SOLVING SOME OF
THEM AS WE AS WE GO ALONG AND
AND AND SERVING THE PEOPLE.
OF OUR STATE BY DOING SO AND I
THINK THE COMMISSION WOULD GO A
LONG WAY TO HELPING.
LEGISLATORS -- UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES AND HAVING A CITIZENS
COMMISSION -- EX YOU KNOW BE AN
EXTENSION OF OUR LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW.
AS MUCH AS I TRY.
TO WORK WITH WITH WITH MEXICO
THEY'RE JUST NOT ENOUGH HOURS OF
THE DAY.
AND AND WE CAN WE NEED HELP.
AND WE NEED TO PUT MORE
RESOURCES INTO THIS AND THIS
WOULD BE A VERY COST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO MOVE.
A LARGE AGENDA ON A DAILY BASIS.
CENTER ALL TAKE THAT IS YOUR
CLOTHES YES.
YEAH WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR RUBIO WITH A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
CAN COR CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
FILE ITEM NINE SB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DODD.
I DODD AYE WILK [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BOARD YES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
[inaudible]
HILL.
HELLO HI WESSEL I WAS SO I'D
JONES [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE WIENER.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES WILL
HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR.
SENATOR JOHN.
SENATOR JONES HERE.
LET'S SEE HIM WHERE WE WE HAVE
ANYBODY.
WIENER WILKINS CALLING NO
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
SERVER WILL HERE ON PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE I'VE GOT PEOPLE
TESTIFYING I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU
PEOPLE.
GOOD THROUGH EVERYTHING.
NO JUST -- YEAH.
I TELL PEOPLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AND
MEMBERS -- TODAY I PRESENT SB.
FIVE FIVE THREE WHICH IS
SUFFICES MORE COMPANIES TO
BECOME A 100% EMPLOYEE OWNED.
I PROVIDING MORE CALIFORNIA'S
WITH A GREATLY ENHANCED PATHWAY --
TO TO RETIREMENT SECURITY.
ABOUT SEVEN AND A HALF MILLION
CALIFORNIA WORKERS.
WORK FOR AN EMPLOYER THEY DOES
NOT OFFER A RETIREMENT PLAN.
NEARLY HALF OF ALL PRIVATE
BUSINESSES ARE OWNED BY BABY
BOOMERS MEANING THAT AS AN OLD
AS A OLDER AMERICANS AGE OUT OF
THE WORK FORCE.
MANY FAMILY AND LOCALLY OWNED
COMPANIES WILL SOON CHANGE HANDS.
RETIRING BUSINESS OWNERS.
COULD SIT CELL TO COMPETITOR
PRIVATE EQUITY GO PUBLIC OR
SIMPLY CLOSER CLOSER DOORS.
BUT THEY CAN ALSO -- CONVERT TO
AN EMPLOYEE STOCK OWNERSHIP PLAN
AND SELL THAT COMPANY TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
AND AESOP IS AN OWNERSHIP
RETIREMENT PLAN WHICH THE
COMPANY CONTRIBUTES IN STOCK OR
MONEY TO BUY ITS STOCK. TO THE
PLAN FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
COMPANY'S OWNER SLASH EMPLOYEES.
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND EASE
SOPS -- TOGETHER EMPLOYED NEARLY
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND WORKERS IN THE COUNTRY
IN NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED OF THOSE
COMPANIES ARE LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA. 65% OF THE SUBS ARE
ALSO PROVIDE A SECOND RETIREMENT
INCOME LIKE US FOR A ONE K. WERE
UNION PENSION.
WHEREAS ONLY 44% OF U. S.
BUSINESSES OFFER ANY RETIREMENT
PLAN AT ALL.
SB FIVE FIVE THREE REQUIRES A
STATE AGENCY AWARDING PUBLIC
WORK CONTRACTS TO PROVIDE A 3%
BID PREFERENCE AT THE EAST SIDE
BITTER IS A HIGHER PERCENT OWNED
AND OPERATED.
BY EMPLOYEE OWNERS AND THE
COMPANY DEMONSTRATES A
DEMONSTRATES COMPLIANCE WITH IRS
REGULATIONS.
WORKERS AT PRIVATE EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE OWNED COMPANIES HAVE
MORE STABLE JOBS BETTER WAGES
AND ENHANCE RETIREMENT SECURITY.
EMPLOYEE OWNED COMPANIES KEEP --
PROFITS IN THE STATE AND USE
THAT MONEY TO BUILD WEALTH FOR
WORKING PEOPLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
BY ADDING A PREFERENCE FOR HE
SOUGHT COMPANIES TO STAY WILL
INCREASE WELL TO RETIRED
CALIFORNIANS TO PRIVATE FUNDING.
LIMITED DEPENDENCE ON PUBLIC
RETIREMENT ANY INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT RETIRED
CALIFORNIANS STAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH AN IMPROVED
EMPLOYEE PRODUCTIVITY.
IT WILL PROVIDE CALIFORNIA WITH
BETTER STRONGER FIRMS AND
EMPLOYEE STABILITY SO WITH ME
TODAY SO WITNESSES MICHAEL SMITH
IS A TWENTY PLUS YEAR EMPLOYEE
SLASH OWNER.
AND SAFETY MANAGER OF A PAYMENT
RECYCLING SOLUTIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT ON HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL
SMITH I AM ON I SAID A TWENTY
TWO YEAR PROUD.
EMPLOYEE OWNER OF PAYMENT
RECYCLING SYSTEMS AND I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING ANOTHER THREE
HUNDRED PLUS EMPLOYEE OWNERS OF
PAPER RECYCLING SYSTEM IN OUR
SUPPORT. FOR SB.
FIVE FIFTY THREE AT FAVOR
RECYCLING SYSTEMS.
ESAU IS WHAT DRIVES OUR COMPANY
YOU STOP IS PROMOTED FROM THE
BEGINNING FROM THE DAY YOU'RE
HIRED IN THE DAY OR BROUGHT INTO
THE COMPANY WAS PROMOTED ON ALL
OF OUR BUSINESS ITEMS ALL OF OUR
BIDS.
IT'S A DAILY -- DISCUSSION WITH
OUR FIELD THIS ON OUR BASSES ON
EVERYTHING WE DO WE PROMOTE HE
SAW.
STOP REMOTES LOYAL WORKERS
STRONG WORKERS WE HAVE NO TURN
OVER VERY LITTLE TURNOVER ONCE
ONCE YOU STOP ONCE PEOPLE
REALIZE THE VALUE OF THE NISSAN.
AND TO BE AN EMPLOYEE OWNER THEY
TEND TO STAY WITH US WHICH MAKES
US A STRONGER COMPANY.
EVERY PERSON IN OUR COMPANY FROM
THE PERSON RUNNING PARTS IN THE
SHOP. TO THE PEOPLE THAT PUT OUT
THE BIDS TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
COMPANY IS AN EQUAL PARTNER IN
EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP THAT'S WHAT
MAKES IT WORK. FOR ME THE SOP
BECAME A REALITY SIXTEEN YEARS
AGO WHEN MY WIFE AND I OPEN UP
OF OUR HOME TO FOSTER CARE.
AND ENDED UP ADOPTING THREE
YOUNG CHILDREN.
MY DAUGHTER GRACE WAS THREE AT
THE TIME IN THE SYSTEM FOR TWO
AND A HALF YEARS.
MY SON DAVID TWO MONTHS LATER A
KNOCK ON THE DOOR AND A PHONE
CALL WE RECEIVED ANOTHER NEWBORN
INFANT -- WHO WAS A SIBLING TO
MY DAUGHTER GRACE? FIVE YEARS
AFTER THE ADOPTION SAID PLACE
AND THROUGH A LOT OF MEDICAL
PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE HAPPENED WE
WERE TOLD THAT GRAYSON ERIN.
AT AUTISM.
AND THAT WOULD REQUIRE A LITTLE
BIT MORE HELP THAN JUST TO
SUPPORT OF MY WIFE BEING A STAY
AT HOME MOM.
MY WIFE WOULD NOW BECOME A STAY
HOME MOM AND AN ADVOCATE TO GET
MY KIDS THE EDUCATION THAT THEY
NEED.
AT THAT AGE MY WIFE AND I AGE A
LITTLE OLDER MOST OF THE PEOPLE
THAT WE KNEW AND OUR FRIENDS
WERE GRADUATING THEIR KIDS FROM
HIGH SCHOOL AND WE'RE LOOKING TO
EMPTY NEST SYNDROME.
AND HOW TO SUPPORT GET READY FOR
RETIREMENT SO IT WAS A LITTLE
SCARY FOR US AS WE KNEW MY WIFE
WOULD NEVER COME BACK INTO.
THE WORK FORCE AND IT WOULD JUST
BE MY INCOME. TEN YEARS AGO OUR
STOCK FOR THE EAST UP CAME OUT
IN MY STOCK ACCOUNT IN THE SUB
THOUSAND DOLLARS AT THAT TIME.
THAT DID A LOT TO EASE OUR MIND
IN THE START WITH OUR KIDS A
LITTLE CLOSER.
FAST FORWARD TO THIS LAST
DECEMBER AND ARE YOU STOP
SHAREHOLDERS MEETING OUR
CHRISTMAS PARTY.
MY WIFE AND I OPEN OUR STOCK
CERTIFICATE AND WE WERE NOW
MILLIONAIRES.
THAT IN TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF
PUTTING SWELLED UP FOR DOING
NOTHING BUT SHOWN UP AND DOING
MY JOB AND BEING A GOOD EMPLOYEE
AND PROMOTING OUR YOU SOFTEN OUR
OWNERSHIP.
WE WERE NOT COMFORTABLE AND WE
KNEW THAT WOULD BE FINE.
WHAT THAT DOES FOR ME AS SIXTY
ONE YEARS OLD NOW IS A GIVES ME
THAT OPPORTUNITY? TO BE ABLE TO
RETIRE THEN TAKE THAT BURDEN OFF
MY WIFE SHOULDER AND CONTINUE
EDUCATING MY KIDS.
MAYBE PROMOTING THE SOP WITH MY
KIDS BY IN THE BUSINESS HELPING
THEM BECOME BETTER IN SOCIETY.
SB FIVE FIFTY THREE WE'RE OPEN
WILL ALSO OPEN THE EYES OF MANY
OTHER CONTRACTORS TO LOOK INTO
THE SOP TO PROMOTE THAT HE'S UP
TO THAT RETIREMENT SO THAT MORE
MORE PEOPLE CAN RETIRE.
WITH THIS NEST EGG THAT THEY'RE
NOT A BURDEN ON THE FAMILY OR
STATE.
SO WITH THAT.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME -- I
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THURMOND ODD -- STEVE WARD --
I'D LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF CERTIFIED EMPLOYEE
OWNED.
AND ESCA.
EMPLOYEE S. CORPSE OF AMERICA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
I TURNED BACK -- TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
CENTER JONES JUST A QUICK
QUESTION S. ZERO GIVE YOU CAN
ADDRESSES ISN'T A MILD CONCERN
THAT -- ADDING ONE MORE
PREFERENCE -- IN THE STATE
CONTRACTING WATERS DOWN SOME OF
THE OTHER PREFERENCES CAN YOU
JUST ADDRESS THAT REAL QUICK.
SURE I SO WHEN THE REASON WHY WE
CHOSE -- 3% SAID 5% SO NOT TO
COMPETE WITH DISABLED.
DENOTE DINO DISABLED -- THAT
VENDORS AND SO THE WHOLE POINT
IT AM I LAST YEAR WE PASSED A A
BIT PRESS -- BID PREFERENCE FOR
THOSE COMPANIES THAT OFFER
HEALTH CARE INSURANCE SO
CERTAINLY THE PRESIDENT IS SET.
I USED TO BE -- PART OF ANY
SOCKS -- TWENTY YEARS AGO AND I
KNOW HOW IT MOTIVATES EMPLOYEES
AND IT CREATES WEALTH AND WHAT
WE WANT TO DO IS TO PAY OFF IN
THIS BUILDING.
WE USE DISINCENTIVES TO GET
PEOPLE TO DO THE RIGHT RIGHT
THING THIS IS AN AN INCENTIVE TO
GET PEOPLE DO THE RIGHT THING
WHICH I THINK WILL.
MAKE EMPLOYEES OWNERS AND AND
AND MORE ENGAGED IN THE BUSINESS
WORK HARDER.
CREATE MORE WEALTH AND THAT THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO THEN YOU KNOW
SHARE IN THE IN THE FRUIT OF
THEIR LABOR SO I THINK THIS OF A
VERY SMART STRATEGY -- QUESTION
THE WITNESS THAT HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES IN YOUR FIRM.
WE ARE OVER THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
ROUND.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE YEAH AB
ANYBODY ELSE WATCHING IF IF I
COULD MISTER CHAIR AND I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN FOND OF THE SHOPS OF
I'VE BEEN AWARE OF THEM FOR MANY
YEARS AND FIND THEM TO BE QUITE
SUCCESSFUL ON ANOTHER A NUMBER
OF ISSUES RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT I CERTAINLY.
AGREE WITH -- SOME OF THEM BUT I
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IT'S
GOING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK IS I TAKE THAT AS A MOTION
SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT -- SIR WILK -- I JUST HAVE
A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL IN THE IMPACT IT HAS ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I THINK IT DELUDE SMALL BUSINESS --
YOUR PREFERENCES AS WELL YEAH
I'M NOT PREPARED TO SUPPORT AT
TODAY BUT WITHOUT ALL LOW WE
YEAH WE'VE WE'VE HAD A
CONVERSATION I APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE THAT YOU SPEND TIME
WITH ME ON THAT.
SO.
AGAIN WE SPEND TOO MUCH TIME.
CREATING DISINCENTIVES FOR
BUSINESS THIS IS AN INCENTIVE
FOR BUSINESSES TO DO THE RIGHT
THING EMPOWER THEIR EMPLOYEES
CREATE MORE WEALTH AND FRANKLY
PROBABLY MAKE PEOPLE LESS
DEPENDENT ON GOVERNMENT MOVING
FORWARD SO WITH THAT I ASKED FOR
AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU CLERK CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE FILE ITEM EIGHT SB FIVE
FIVE THREE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DODD.
GOD NO WILK.
I WILL.WILK HI ALLEN [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HELLO.
HELLO HI WES SO.
JONES I'VE.
JONES HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
K.. FOUR TO ONE HOLD.
SO WITH THAT HAS -- IT'S FOUR
ONE WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOVED OUT MISTER CHAIR JUST TO
GET THIS ON THE WAY IF I FALL
SHORT OF LIKE DANCE FOR
RECONSIDERATION LET ME THINK YES
YOU.
MOST CERTAINLY HAVE -- WILL MOVE
NOW TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB --
SEVEN ONE SEVEN CENTER JONES.
THIS FEATURE THANK YOU I WILL
VOUCH FOR MY COLLEAGUES THAT ARE
MISSING FROM THIS COMMITTEE THEY
ARE IN YOUR NATURAL RESOURCES
WHERE WE ARE -- GOTTEN THROUGH
THREE OF THE ISSUES OF THE DAY
SO -- WILL BE THERE A WHILE -- I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMITTEE WANTS A LONG AND
LENGTHY PRESENTATION WITH A LOT
TO DETAILS REGARDING THIS BILL.
AND NORMS KING -- CURRENT LAW
OFFERS A TIGHT HOUSE EXEMPTION
TO ALCOHOL MANUFACTURERS THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO BUY ADVERTISING
SPACE AT STADIUMS IN SPORTS
ARENAS.
SB SEVEN SEVENTEEN CODIFIES
EXISTING PRACTICE BY EXPLICITLY
INCLUDING CRAFT DISTILLERS IN
THIS EXEMPTION WITH ME TODAY I
RICHARD HARRIS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ARTISANAL DISTILLERS
GUILD IF THERE HAPPENS TO BE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SIR YEAH MISTER
CHAIRMAN RICHARD HARRIS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE JUST
THINK CODIFYING THIS MAKES SENSE
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WITNESSES SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- TO MOVE THE
BILL IT TO APPROPRIATIONS IS HAS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN AS BE SEVEN ONE
SEVEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DOT.
HI.
DODD I WILL DIE WILK AYE ALLEN
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
AT FIRST I'D CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HILL.
HILL AYE WEST SO.
JONES I'VE JONES I NIELSEN
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
AT SEVEN ZERO ZERO AB BILLS --
SEVEN ZERO WILL HOLD OUT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
RIGHT AWAY.
CENTER STERN I CURRENTLY IS ON
HIS WAY
[inaudible]
THAT WAS
OPEN THE ROLE IF FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS CLERK CAN YOU
PLEASE -- START AT THE TOP
STARTING IN.
STARTING WITH CONSENT.
CONSENT CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
WEST SO [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
WIENER.
AS PROJECTED FILE ITEM TO SB ONE
SIXTY MOTIONS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BEAU IS FIVE TWO
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS WILK.
BY.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D FORGES
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHIANG [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
WIENER.
SO IT SEVEN ZERO WILL STILL
HOLDING OPEN.
FILE ITEM MADE AS THE FIVE FIVE
THREE MOTIONS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS
VOTE IS FORTY ONE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
WAGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
GALGIANI I DON'T KNOW.
GALGIANI I DON'T KNOW
[inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
WESSEL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER.
YES FORTY TO LOWER BILL.
ALL I FIND REDUCE PROJECT OKAY
SORRY FORTY TWO WILL HOLD THAT
OPEN.
ITEM NINE SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
YEAH BEAU IS FIVE ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS WILK WHICH ONE FIVE FIVE
EIGHT WHY SO -- YES HI HI.
WILK AYE ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D FORGES
[inaudible]
BRADFORD. FOR I CHIANG
GLAZER [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
WIENER.
AT EIGHT TWO ZERO WILL STILL
HOLD THAT OPEN.
ITEM TWELVE SB SIX SEVENTY
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BEAU IS SIX TWO ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS WILK HI.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA AYE BARGES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
WEST SO.
JONES. SIX SEVENTY SIX SEVENTY
FIVE JONES I WIENER.
SO THAT'S TEN ZERO WILL STILL
HOLD THAT OPEN.
ITEM THIRTEEN SB SEVEN ONE SEVEN
MOTIONS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D FORGES
[inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
WEST SO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
WIENER. SEVEN EIGHT ZERO WILL
HOLD THAT OPEN.
OKAY WE'RE BACK IN THE HOLD.
BOWED WAITING.
FOR THE NEXT AUTHOR THINK
SUPPOSEDLY IS SIR SENATOR SIR.
THIS YEAR DO YOU WANNA ADAM MY
VOTE SIR.
YOUR PRINTER ONE MORE TIME -- NO.
IF WE JUST DID IT WILL OKAY.
THE ME LET ME GO THROUGH.
MOVED TO ATTACK.
THE ASKING THE CALL EVERYBODY'S
NAME BUT I THINK WE HAVE.
TO WELL.
NOT TECHNICALLY OKAY WELL ARE WE
WAITING FOR ARE WE WAITING FOR
CENTER STERN.
I'LL HEAD BACK DOWN A NOTCH
RESOURCES AND WHAT HANG ON LET'S
GET YOU GET JOINT OKAY.
YOU MAY BE WAITING FOR ME TO
COME BACK DOWN.
TO OKAY SO ON DISPLAY WILL DO
THREE OF THEM [inaudible]
OKAY.
IN.
TRY TO HELP YOU KNOW ME.
I'VE AYE FOR **** I CAN FEEL IT.
CONSENT CALENDAR JONES.
WHY JONES I'D LEVIN ZERO HOLD IT
UP -- ITEM TO SB ONE SIXTY I DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN ZERO JONES.
JOHN. FIVE EIGHT ZERO SEVEN ITEM
NINE SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT MOTION
IS YOU HAVE TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO JONES.
JOHN HI NINE ZERO WILL DO.
WELL DONE SENATOR
.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME AGAIN.
CATCH MY BREATH RAN THE FIRST
TWO YEARS -- SO YOU KNOW.
THERE'S NO SPONSOR THIS BILL
WHICH I KINDA LIKE.
LIKE SPONSORED BILLS TOO MUCH
BUT THE HONEST INSPIRATIONS MY
CHIEF OF STAFF WAS A SCIENCE
FELLOW.
WHO'S GOT A PHD IN THEORETICAL
PHYSICS.
HE'S WELL AS ALBERT EINSTEIN
TYPE PEOPLE.
AND CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA
THANKS PRETTY COOL -- FOR A STEM
[inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
BASICALLY.
WE ENGAGE IN ALL THESE VARIOUS
EFFORTS IN GOVERNMENT TO TRY.
TO YOU KNOW DEAL WITH SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND
MATHEMATICS.
AND THE IDEA I THINK THE CORE OF
IT IS IN ESSENCE WAS TRIMMING
MEMBERS.
THAT.
WE HAVE WE RESPECT THOSE IDEAS.
IAN -- THE FORM OF DESIGNATING
[inaudible]
THIS.
I HAVE IS YOU SHOULD HAVE IN
YOUR PACKET.
A WHOLE BUNCH OF LETTERS TO
SENATOR ASOS DISTRICT FROM
SCHOOL CENTERS -- DROSS IS
DISTRICT -- SUPPORTING THIS IDEA.
OF A CALIFORNIA LAUREATE OF STEM --
FOR FOR THE GOVERNMENT SO.
CERTAINLY WE KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD
A LOT OF NOBEL LAUREATES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA EIGHTY FIVE IN FACT.
AND FIFTY RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY FIVE
WHICH ARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THE IDEA IS JUST
PHILOSOPHICALLY BEING CONSISTENT
WITH THESE CORE VALUES THAT HAVE
BEEN A CORNERSTONE OF SO MUCH
INNOVATION OF CALIFORNIA.
SO MUCH OF WHAT EFFORTS HAVE
BEEN PUT IN -- EDUCATION
COMMITTEES AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO SO WE THOUGHT THIS WAS
KIND OF A NICE COMPLIMENT TO
THAT LARGER DYNAMIC IN WITH THAT.
A TWO OVER TO MY GREAT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED TEAR DODD
AND AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS AMBER MAY SIGNED THE
INTERIM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY OR C. C.
S. T..
AND WE ARE A NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT WE WE WERE CREATED AT
THE REQUEST OF THE LEGISLATURE
SO WE DON'T TAKE POSITIONS ON
BILLS BUT I'M VERY VERY HAPPY TO
BE HERE. TO TALK ABOUT SCIENCE
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF SCIENCE IN
THE WORK THAT YOU DO IN THE IN
THE WORK OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SCIENCE FOR SOCIETY SO
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MANY WORLD
CLASS ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS AND
RESEARCH FACILITIES.
AND WE PARTNER WITH THEM VERY
CLOSELY TO HELP BRIDGE THE GAP
BETWEEN SCIENCE AND POLICY
THROUGH A SUITE OF SERVICES THAT
WE BRING TO YOU BRIEFINGS
STUDIES AND OF COURSE ARE CCSD
SCIENCE FELLOWS.
THANKS TO THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE
BEEN MENTORS TO THEM.
AND WE SEE THAT THERE'S A STRONG
DESIRE IN FACT AN UNENDING NEED
FOR SCIENTISTS TO COMMUNICATE
WITH WITH AUDIENCES OF ALL
LEVELS. TO SHOW WHO SCIENTISTS
ARE AND THE BRING THE VALUE OF
SCIENCE TO ALL OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE FACE AS A SOCIETY.
SO IT'S PUBLIC RESEARCH THAT WE
RELY ON TO SOLVE THESE COMPLEX
ISSUES THAT CALIFORNIA FACES
IT'S ALSO PUBLIC OUTREACH BY
SCIENTISTS THAT IS AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT TO OPENING THE DOORS
TO STEM CAREERS WE NEED THIS
PIPELINE OF THE SCIENCE SAVVY
STUDENTS.
WHO ARE GOING TO HELP US SOLVE
THESE PROBLEMS THAT WE FACE AS A
SOCIETY?
AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE STUDENTS GET TO MEET
SCIENTISTS FIRST HAND AND IT'S
WHEN THEY MEET THE SCIENTISTS IN
PERSON THEY SEE THAT ANYONE CAN
BE A SCIENTIST.
AND THAT SCIENTISTS CAN DO
ANYTHING WHETHER AS A HIGH
SCHOOL CHEMISTRY TEACHER AS AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR SENATOR OR AS
A RESEARCHER.
THE MYSTERIES OF THE UNIVERSE.
SO WE KNOW THAT OUR REACH TAKES
TIME IT'S OFTEN PRO BONO IT'S
OFTEN UNRECOGNIZED AND
UNSUPPORTED THAT'S WHY US DUMB
LAURIE IT IS THE TYPE OF
POSITION THAT REALLY.
ELEVATES THE ROLE OF SCIENCE AND
GIVES SCIENCE OF VOICE TO
INSPIRE THOSE WHO ARE COMING UP
AND WHO WILL BE OUR FUTURE
LEADERS.
THERE IS AN URGENT NEED TO
EXPAND AND SOLIDIFY A STRONG
ROLE FIRST STEM IN OUR SOCIETY
CALIFORNIA ALWAYS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THESE ISSUES AND WE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO PLAY A
LEADING ROLE.
IT'S VITAL THAT SCIENTISTS WHO
DEDICATE TIME TO SCIENCE
COMMUNICATION AND PUBLIC
OUTREACH ARE RECOGNIZED.
BECAUSE THEIR EFFORTS ARE
ESSENTIAL THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE SHOULD TAKE ALL
OPPORTUNITIES TO AFFIRM.
THAT THE STATE VALUES STEM
CAREERS AND THAT CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIANS ARE STRONGER WITH
SCIENCE THANK YOU THANK YOU
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ERIN RODRIGUEZ WITH
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS WE
ALSO THINK SCIENCE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT -- ESPECIALLY OUR
DEMOCRACY AND IT'S OFF SOME OF
OUR REALLY PRESSING FRAUD
PROBLEMS ORDERS BE SEEN SO I'M
FOR INSTRUCTS FOR THANKS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PACMAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS FROM STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT CAPS HAS
BEEN DOING -- FOR THIRTY ONE
YEARS AS EVIDENCED BY THE THIRTY
FIRST ANNUAL STATE SIGNED TO
STAY WHICH WILL BE HELD ON MAY
EIGHTH ON THE WEST STEPS OF THE
CAPITOL WE INVITE YOU ALL TO
ATTEND AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
TORE AS ON BEHALF OF CO DOT ORG
INTACT AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HI JULIE BAKER FROM CALIFORNIANS
FOR THE ARTS AND WOULD LOVE TO
SEE THIS AMENDMENT AMENDED TO
INCLUDE THE A FOR ARTS AND TO
MAKE IT STEM.
ODD TO GO TO STEAM THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANY [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
NO OPPOSITION -- TURNED BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
CENTER CHIANG.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I USED
TO RUN A SITE CENTER FOR KIDS --
PRIOR TO SERVING IN AND
LEGISLATURE NICE WANT TO THANK.
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
ISSUE FORWARD AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD LOVE.
TO GOING ON AS A CO AUTHOR
THANKS AGAIN FOR THIS THANK YOU.
GOT THAT FREDDIE W. MOTION
CENTER CHIANG.
THANK YOU FOR THAT MOTION --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR.
GETS I'M SORRY IT CENTER WILL
COME IN AND SEE FOR A YEAR OFF
OF ME UP TODAY MISTER CHAIR.
SO I USE A GREAT IDEA -- THE
ONLY WAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO CREATE WEALTH AND
DEAL WITH OUR MAJOR ISSUES LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGE IS THROUGH
INNOVATION HIM TO DO THAT WE
NEED SCIENTISTS.
I WAS JUST CURIOUS IF YOU'RE
OPEN TO THE TO THE MAMMOTH THAT
WAS PROPOSED -- WHEN THOSE IN
TERMS OF ADDING ARTS AS WELL
YEAH WELL LOOK HERE'S MY
THINKING A GUY GIVEN TOPIC I'M
BIG GIGANTIC BELIEVE IN THE ARTS
I GOT A SON?
WHO'S A CLASSICAL MUSIC COMPOSER
I LIVE THIS STUFF EVERY DAY OF
MY LIFE AT LIKE SIX PHONE CALLS
THIS MORNING ALREADY.
HE'S YOU KNOW AND IT'S I REALLY
I'M A BELIEVER THE QUESTION I
NEED SOME DIAGNOSTIC HERE AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT.
I MEAN CERTAINLY HAVE SOMEBODY
IN THE ARTS WORLD WE HAVE A POET
LAUREATE.
AND IN THE ARTS WORLD IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT MUCH
ORGANIC BELIEVER THE QUESTION I
I NEED SOME DIAGNOSTIC ON IT WAS
JUST REYES TO ME.
IS WHETHER OR NOT YOU NEED -- TO
VERSES THE IDEA OF THE FOCUS ON
SCIENCE I COULD SEE BILL NYE THE
SCIENCE GUY IS PROBABLY THE
RICHEST PERSON BUT YOU KNOW TO
NOT THE FUSE ONE VERSUS THE
OTHER WE HAVE A SITUATION WHERE.
THE REPORTS ESTIMATE THAT WE
HAVE A MILLION MORE STEM
PROFESSIONALS THAT REQUIRE IN
THE NEXT DECADE THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES.
IN THE WITH THE LOOT THAT
EMPHASIS WOULD GET BOTH WITH ART
AND WITH RESPECT TO SCIENCE SO
THAT'S THE ONLY QUESTION I REYES
LOOK I'D LOVE I'M ALL IN YOU
KNOW FOR THE ARTS PEACE.
BUT MAYBE IT SHOULD BE SOMETHING
SEPARATE SOME OF YOU HAVE
THOUGHT ABOUT IT I HAVE THOUGHT
ABOUT IT.
I LIVE THIS MY LIFE LIKE YOU
KNOW IT'S KIND OF COOL.
RIGHT JUST ON THE CLOSE THIS IS
BASICALLY NOT SO MEMBERS THE USE
USE THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
WILL CHOOSE THE NOMINEES.
NOMINEES THEY SERVE FOR TWO
YEARS APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR --
A KIND OF SIMILAR TO THE NOBEL
LAUREATE BUT SOMETHING THAT
REALLY EMPHASIZES WHAT ABOUT MY
STATEMENT ABOUT WHO WE ARE
CALIFORNIA HOPEFULLY OTHER
STATES AND THE NATIONAL
GOVERNMENT.
CAN -- FOLLOW IN OUR FOOTSTEPS
AS THEY HAVE BEEN SO MANY OTHER
RESPECTS AS FROM MY BOOK.
FILED. THREE SB TWO THREE SEVEN
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD
AYE DODD AYE WILK HI WILK AYE
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BARGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I BRADFORD I'D CHANGE.
CHANGE HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL.
HELLO HI WES SO [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER. SIX SIX ZERO THE BILL
HAS SIX VOTES -- SENATOR WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR UP TO MEMBERS
THANK YOU YOUR STERN CENTER
STERN [inaudible]
GOOD [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
PFISTER CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR.
THE STATE HAD A BUSY MORNING.
IT'S BEEN A IT'S BEEN A DAY.
LET'S GET STARTED THANK YOU
PLEASE THANK YOU -- HERE TO
PRESENT TO YOU SB [inaudible]
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT YOUNG PEOPLE
[inaudible]
OFTEN.
OUR REGARDING OUR DEMOCRACY
SILENTLY -- WHEN YOU'RE UNDER
EIGHTEEN YOU DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE?
OR CONTROL YOUR OWN FUTURE
NECESSARILY OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO ON YOUR BEHALF.
THE ONE THING THAT.
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO SOLVE WITH
HIS BILL TODAY'S TO ACTUALLY
GIVE.
THE NEXT GENERATION OF VOICE
THROUGH ART.
BY ESTABLISHING YOUTH POET
LAUREATE.
WE BUILD ON OUR TRADITION IN
THIS STATE FOR OUR POET LAUREATE
WHICH IS BEEN A WONDERFUL
TRADITION.
BY LOOKING TO THE NEXT
GENERATION TO STEP UP AND LEAD.
SO I A I DON'T WANT TO BELABOR
THIS BECAUSE MY WORDS ARE PALTRY
COMPARED TO OUR LEAD WITNESS
HERE TODAY NATALIA MISIA'S --
THE POETRY OUT LOUD -- COUNTY
CHAMPION FROM ALAMEDA FROM
STANLEY ENTER TO BE SPECIFIC SO.
I'LL JUST KEEP IT SHORT AND
SWEET AND SAY FOLKS LIKE ME
SHOULD TALK LESS AND THIS NEXT
GENERATION SHOULD SPEAK OUT MORE.
BUT THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I'VE FOUGHT.
RIGHT YOU CAN SEE.
RIGHT WERE FOR MORE YOU ARE
PERFECT WE GOT A MIKE THERE FOR
YOU.
EACH PRESS THAT GREEN BUTTON.
IS IT ON GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING -- THIS POEM IS CALLED
IN LATVIA.
PEOPLE COME LOOKING FOR THE POOR.
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO NEED TO A
SKATE.
THEY END UP IN TRASH BACKS.
LEFT TO ROT ON THEIR FAMILIES DO.
CSUS BARBAROUS BARBARA'S THE
TOWNSPEOPLE SAY AFTER THEY HEAR
THE NAME.
GONE TOO SOON AS THOMAS.
HE WAS THE EIGHTH THIS.
ONE GUESS SEVEN MONTHS.
SOMETIMES I CATCH MY WILL LEAD
TO A LOOKING INTO THE BLANK
SPACE IN FRONT OF HIS HANDS.
THAT RESTED LIGHTLY ON THE TABLE
WHILE HE THINKS NO ONE IS
WATCHING [inaudible]
HEAD TILTED.
WAITING FOR A FAMILIAR VOICE.
ALL YES.
LISTEN KESAVAN MEDIA SEVENTY
EIGHT ON THE LAST THROWBACKS.
I'VE SEEN IT'S AFFECTS HOW IT
CAN BECOME THICKER THAN BLOOD
WRAP AROUND TV GROUPS YANK OUT
FROM THE SOIL OF MY ANCESTORS
RIGHT UNDER MY FEET.
LET ME SHOW YOU HOW I BECOME A
WOMAN WITHOUT A COUNTRY.
AT THE END I DOESN'T FEEL THE
SAME FROM WHEN I WAS.
SEVEN THESE HOUSES.
NOW FILLED WITH HEAVY I THESE
ROADS STAINED WITH EVEN MORE
BLOOD.
BUT THIS BLOOD DOES NOT KERRY
THE PRIDE OF MY VIA SCARLET
TINGE OF REVOLUTION [inaudible]
PLEASE.
OUR BLOSSOMS OF DEFEAT.
I LOOKED AWAY FOR JUST A MOMENT.
AND IT HAD ALL CHANGED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN DIED IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M AND BOUND
CRAWFORD AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL --
I'M.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ALLEN
TESTIMONY ON SB.
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT THE YOUTH POET
LAUREATE BILL.
GRATEFUL TO SENATOR STERN ALONG
WITH SENATORS ALAN AND HERTZBERG
FOR AUTHORING THIS BILL.
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
SUBMITTED A FORMAL REQUEST TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO BRING
LEGISLATION TO ESTABLISH A
CALIFORNIA POET LAUREATE.
WILL BE APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
NEW SOME.
AND CONFIRMED BY SENATE FROM A
LIST OF THREE NOMINEES.
THERE WILL BE PROVIDED BY THE
ARTS COUNCIL THROUGH A SPECIFIC
PROCESS.
THE CALIFORNIA POET LAUREATE.
IS IS SOMETHING.
THERE HAS BEEN TREMENDOUSLY
SUCCESSFUL AND I WOULD LOVE TO
TO EXTEND IT TO THE YOUTH IN
THIS STATE.
BECAUSE IT LENDS THEM AGENCY.
I AM THROUGH MY EXPERIENCE AS AN
EDUCATOR I'VE SEEN OVER AND OVER
AGAIN HOW POWERFUL THE
EXPERIENCES WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE
SEE ONE OF THEIR PEERS CREATING.
AND BEING CELEBRATED AND VALUED
IN THIS CASE AS A POET.
THE POET LAUREATE.
WOULD HAVE A MISSION TO ADVOCATE
FOR THE ART OF POETRY.
IN CLASSROOMS AND COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE TO INSPIRE AND
EMERGING GENERATION OF LITERARY
ARTISTS AND TO EDUCATE ALL
CALIFORNIANS ABOUT THE MANY
POETS AND AUTHORS WHO HAVE
INFLUENCED.
OUR GREAT STATE THROUGH CREATIVE
LITERARY EXPRESSION.
I'M HERE TODAY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL'S
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS.
KRISTIN MARGOLIS YOU CAN HE AND
SHE WILL TELL YOU MORE ABOUT THE
POET THAT WE BROUGHT WITH US
TODAY.
AND ABOUT THE LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CHAIRMAN DIED I JUST WANNA TELL
YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT -- WHY WE
ARE SO LUCKY TO HAVE AN ITALIAN
HERE SO SHE PARTICIPATED IN
POETRY OUT LOUD -- AND THIS YEAR
WE HAD FIFTY THREE COUNTIES THAT
PARTICIPATED -- WITH OVER FORTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
SO AT THE INTEREST IN.
READING POETRY -- IS IS HUGE
AMONG KIDS THAT ARE IN TIS AGE
RANGE -- THIRTEEN TO NINETEEN
THAT PARTICULAR CONTEST IS ABOUT
READING OTHER POETRY SO IT'S ONE
PRE TWENTIETH CENTURY UPON AND
ONE POEM THAT MAYBE CURRENT DAY
AND THEN THEY'RE ABLE TO SELECT
FROM ANOTHER POEM OUT OF EIGHT
HUNDRED HOMES THAT ARE ON A
WEBSITE.
BUT THE UPON THAT YOU HEARD
ITALIAN RECITE TODAY AS PART OF
A PROGRAM CALLED POETRY
OURSELVES WHICH IS AN OFFSHOOT
OF POETRY OUT LOUD AND IT'S THE
FIRST YEAR THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY
DONE THAT PROGRAM -- WITH
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL AS AN
OFFSHOOT OF POETRY OUT LOUD AND
SO.
THAT HOME IS WHAT SHE SAID MATED --
TO THAT CONTEST AND THERE ARE
MANY OTHER STUDENTS WERE VERY
INTERESTED IN DOING THAT.
AND IT'S REALLY RAISE THE
AWARENESS -- OF THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL MEMBERS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE YOUTH POET
LAUREATES.
I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT POINT
OUT TO YOU THAT WE THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THE GOVERNOR
MAKES HIS APPOINTMENT BASED ON
THE FACT THAT.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE ALSO
INTERESTED IN PARTICIPATING IN
PUBLIC SERVICE AND SO BY SERVING
AS A YOUTH POET LAUREATE THEY
WOULD HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY --
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO IDENTIFY THESE
YOUNG WRITERS AND LITERARY
SCHOLARS -- SO THAT THEY CAN BE
COMMITTED TO CIVIC AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AS WELL.
pWE THINK SENATOR STERN VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN A
CAPPING WINTER PRISON AND
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR ARTS
EDUCATION WANT TO THANK SENATOR
STERN IN THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL.
AND THAT THE YOUNG PERSON
TESTIFYING -- WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN FOR
AUTHORING THE BILL MY NAME'S
JULIE BAKER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR THE ARTS
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M JEFFREY WEISSMAN --
EDUCATOR MENTOR OF USE IN THE
POETRY ALLOWED -- PROGRAM IS
OUTSTANDING AND NEEDS A OF A
WONDERFUL SYMBOL AT THE HIGHER
LEVEL TO INSPIRE AYE I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
EIGHTY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR WELL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AT CREATIVE ECONOMY IS
SEVEN FRIEDMAN OF SORRY GIVE ME
SECOND RESCUE CENTER NOT ALSO.
GOT -- THE MOTION WAS FROM
NIELSEN ALL RIGHT.
IT'S BEEN A LONG MORNING IT AS
SO WE HAVE A MOTION.
NIELSEN.
ANYBODY ALSO THE DICE LIKE TO
SPEAK BEFORE I MOVE IT ALONG.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
OF A CONDOM IS 7% OF THE STATE'S
GDP IT'S LARGER THAN EVEN
AGRICULTURE TRANSPORTATION IN
THIS NEXT GENERATION DESERVES A
VOICE IN THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I'VE OF CENTER THIS MOTION
HAS THIS BILL HAS A DO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROPRIATIONS
CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SB SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DODD I THOUGHT I
WILL.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA [inaudible]
FORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
CHANGE HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL.
HILL AYE.
WESSEL [inaudible]
JOHN.
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER. SEVEN ZERO
HOPE THAT OPEN AT THE BILL
ENJOYS SEVEN VOTES WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
LEGISLATING ON SENATOR.
WE HAVE WORD SENATOR WIENER IS --
SETTING UP BILL IN ITS ON THE
OPPOSITION SIDE NOW SO -- HURRY
UP AND WAIT --
WE HAVE AN ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB. ONE THE LAST
BILL OF THE DAY FOR THIS
COMMITTEE -- CENTER WIENER GOOD
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR WAITING.
ALL GOOD.
MORNING
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK GOD THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US CLOSELY ON THE
BILL -- TO IMPROVE MECHANICS --
OF THE BILL WE APPRECIATE THAT --
WERE COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER -- AND I'M HAPPY
TO ACCEPT OUR AMENDMENTS ONE
FOUR AND FIVE LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS -- GOING FORWARD WE
WILL WORK WITH THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ON
AMENDMENTS TO AND THREE RELATING
TO COST ISSUES SO WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK WITH US AND YOUR
FLEXIBILITY -- AND HELPING WITH
THE BELT -- COLLEAGUES -- SB TWO
EIGHTY ONE IS FUNDAMENTALLY A
LOCAL BILL THAT WILL DO TWO
THINGS -- NUMBER ONE IT WILL --
AND GUN SHOWS AT THE COW PALACE
WHICH IS LOCATED IN DALY CITY --
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF IT CROSSING
OVER IN SAN FRANCISCO -- AND IT
WILL ALSO -- CREATE A LOCAL
DECISION MAKING -- ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF THE CAL PALACE ONSITE.
I WANT TO KNOW -- THAT FIRST OF
ALL THIS BILL IS A CO AUTHORED
BY EVERY SINGLE MEMBER.
OF THE LEGISLATURE WHO
REPRESENTS EITHER CEMETERY
COUNTY OR SAN FRANCISCO ALL SIX
OF US THANK YOU CENTER HILL FOR
YOUR CO AUTHORSHIP.
IT ALSO ENJOYS -- UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT FROM THE DALY CITY
COUNCIL -- I THAT WAS FOR SOME
REASON I IN THE ANALYSIS OR THEY
DID SUBMIT A LETTER -- UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SUPPORT
FROM THE MAYOR OF SAN FRANCISCO
LONDON BREED -- AND WE HAD THE
CEMETERY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WILL BE VOTING ON
ENDORSING THE BILL TODAY -- THE
DISTRICT SUPERVISORS FURTHER
CANNOT BUT WHO ALSO SUBMITTED A
LETTER SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
THIS IS NOT CONTROVERSIAL
LOCALLY AND WHAT THIS.
REALLY SPRINGS FROM AND THE
REASON WHY THIS BILL IS NOT
CONTROVERSIAL LOCALLY.
UNANIMOUS VOTES UNANIMOUS
DELEGATION SUPPORT IS BECAUSE
FOR MANY MANY YEARS -- THE CAL
PALACE AND ITS BOARD OF
DIRECTORS -- HAVE BEEN ENTIRELY
ON RESPONSIVE. TO THE NEEDS OF
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
THE I KNOW EVERYONE IS FAMILIAR
WITH THE GUN SHOW ISSUE THAT.
FOR MANY MANY YEARS THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN ASKING THE
CAL PALACE TO STOP PUTTING ON
GUN SHOWS IN THE HEART BAY AREA.
AND FOR MANY MANY YEARS THE
CALIFORNICUM.
AND BLOWN OFF THE DESIRE OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY TEND TO GUN
SHOWS BUT THAT'S JUST THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG.
CALIPARI SITS ON SIXTY ACRES OF
LAND.
HI RIGHT IN THE HEART OF THE BAY
AREA WHEN YOU ADD THE
SURROUNDING PARCELS IT'S OVER
EIGHTY ACRES OF LAND -- IN A
REGION THAT HAS A TERRIBLE
HOUSING CRISIS FOR MANY MANY
YEARS.
DALY CITY HAS BEEN ASKING THE
CALIPARI'S WORK COLLABORATIVELY
TO MAKE BETTER USE OF THE LAB.
WHICH COULD INCLUDE KEEPING THE
CAL PALACE AND REDEVELOPING
OTHER PARTS OF THIS OF THE
LARGEST PARKING LOT OF EVER SEEN
IN MY LIFE -- TO ADD HOUSING AND
A MIXED USE NEIGHBORHOOD FOR A
PART OF DALY CITY THE DOESN'T
EVEN HAVE A GROCERY STORE -- AND
FOR YEARS AND YEARS THE CALIPARI
BOARD OF DIRECTORS HAVE BLOWN
OFF ONCE AGAIN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND NOTHING HAS
HAPPENED -- AND SO WHAT THIS
BILL WILL DO IS WITH THE
AMENDMENTS IT WILL AUTHORIZE.
TGS OR WILL REQUIRE THE GS TO
ENTER IN THE CONVERSATIONS WITH
A LOCALLY CREATED AUTHORITY
COMPRISED OF DALY CITY SAN
FRANCISCO AND SAN MATTEO COUNTY.
AND TO ATTEMPT TO NEGOTIATE THE
SALE OF THE CAL PALACE -- TO
THIS LOCAL AUTHORITY -- THE BILL
DOES NOT REQUIRE TGS TO
CONSUMMATE THAT SALE BUT IT DOES
REQUIRE THAT THERE AT LEAST BE A
CONVERSATION AND THEN AUTHORIZES
OUTSELL.
IF TGS DETERMINES THAT IT'S IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE STATE --
TO MAKE A SALE.
THE BILL ALSO PERMANENTLY BANNED
A GUN SHOWS AT THE SITE WHOEVER
ENDS UP.
OWNING IT.
ON COLLEAGUES I WISH WE DID NOT
HAVE TO BE HERE -- FOR THIS BILL
I WISH THAT THE CAL PALACE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS -- WOULD.
FOR YEARS AND YEARS I'VE WORKED
WITH THE COMMUNITY -- AND
UNDERSTOOD THAT EVEN THOUGH THE
CAL PALACE IS TECHNICALLY A
STATE.
PROPERTY AND A STATE ENTITY THAT
HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH ITS
NEIGHBORS IT HAS NOT DONE SO
DESPITE DECADES OF REQUEST.
HOW MANY SENATORS REPRESENTING
DALY CITY?
HAVE TO INTRODUCE LEGISLATION
BEFORE THE CAL PALACE LISTENS
I'M NOW THE THIRD AFTER JACKIE
SPEAR AND MARK LENO.
AND YET YOU THINK THEY WILL TAKE
IN THE HANDS.
THAT MAYBE THEY SHOULD WORK
COLLABORATIVE GROUP BUT THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY THEY HAVEN'T
DONE SO AND SO NOW IT'S TIME TO
TRY TO MOVE IN A MORE POSITIVE
DIRECTION FOR OUR COMMUNITY --
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
THOUGH -- WITH ME TODAY ARE.
WE'LL DUPLICITY REPRESENTING --
DALY CITY AND KAREN LYING
REPRESENTING THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
CHAIRMAN SENATORS A BILL TO
CLOSE THE REPRESENTING DALY CITY
THE THE CAL POWER IS DOMINATED
AREA OF DALY CITY CALLED THE BAY
SHORE NEIGHBORHOOD.
IT IS BECOME -- SOMETHING THAT
NONE OF YOU WOULD WANT IN YOUR
DISTRICTS AND I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU WOULD THE SUPPORT CENTER
WINNERS -- LEGISLATION WHICH
HOPEFULLY WILL ALLOW THE LOCAL
OF THE LOCALLY ELECTED OFFICIALS
IN THE TWO COUNTIES IN SAID
PRINCIPALLY THE CITY OF DALY
CITY.
TO BE ABLE TO SERVE THEIR
RESIDENTS AS THEY SHOULD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I CHARACTERS RETURN MEMBERS
CAROLING ON BEHALF OF MARYLAND
AND BREED AND THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE TODAY THE
BILL SAYS FORD AWAY FOR IT THAT --
THE CAPITALIST TO BE MORE
RESPONSIVE TO LOCAL INPUT AND
LOCAL CONCERNS THEIR ENJOYS THE
SUPPORT AS A SICK AS A SENATOR
SIDE OF ALL OF THE LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND THE COMMUNITY WE
ASK FOR EITHER TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK FROM CRUISE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY -- SUPERVISOR CAN'T
UP AS IN SUPPORT IN THE SAN
MATTEO BOARD IS PICKING IT UP
TODAY SO WE SHOULD HAVE A
POSITION SHORTLY.
WHAT JOHNSON HERE MATH TEACHERS
FEW ALTAMONT YOUR CHILD SUPPORT --
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
.
IN A PLEASE GIVE A SHORT
[inaudible]
OKAY -- I'D LIKE TO GIVE EQUAL
TIME TO USE SO LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE DID HAVE A LONG
PRESENTATION THERE.
SO -- PLEASE -- BE EXPEDITIOUS
IN YOUR COMMENTS IF YOU CAN.
GO AHEAD THANK YOU -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
YOU'VE HEARD THE MYTHS.
AND LET ME DISCUSS THE MATS THE
FIRST ONE IS IT'S NOT
CONTROVERSIAL IT'S CONTROVERSIAL.
YOU'RE TAKING STATE PROPERTY ONE
OF FIFTY FOUR AGRICULTURAL
DISTRICTS.
WITH ANOTHER TWENTY THREE OR SO
FAIRS AND EXPOSITIONS.
AND YOU ARE TRANSFERRING AT TO A
GROUP OF ENTITIES ONE OF WHICH
DALY CITY.
IS NEARLY INSOLVENT.
AND EVERYBODY IN THE TWENTY
CITIES OF SAN MTTEO COUNTY
KNOWS THE FINANCIAL CONDITION.
OF DALY CITY.
IF THE AREA IS DEPRESSED.
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT.
DALY CITY IS THE AREA.
THE AUTHOR TALKS ABOUT THERE'S
NO GROCERY STORE.
I HAPPEN TO A BAND Là LAWYER
FOR THE GROCERY STORE YEARS AGO.
BEFORE THE AUTHOR EVER KNOW --
THERE WAS A JOURNEY BUT I HAVE
IN YOU BOB LONG.
AND HE HAD TO GO OUT OF BUSINESS
BECAUSE HE WASN'T PROTECTED BY
DALY CITY. ONE OF THE OTHER
MATHS.
IS THAT THE LOCAL COMMUNITY --
IS NOT USING.
THE CAL BALANCES THOUGH THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS IS SOME
MARROW IN AND HAAS STYLE
CONDITION TORE.
LOCAL COMMUNITY 95% OF WAGES IN
DALY CITY IN OF A COUPLE OF
ACRES AND NOW SAN FRANCISCO USES
FOR POLICE DEPARTMENT TRAINING
FOR FIRE DEPARTMENT TRAINING.
FIRST WHAT TEAM SO C. H. B. USES
AT THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
DEPARTMENT USES IT FOR TRAINING.
EIGHT NINE TEN YEARS AGO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA STOP PUTTING
UP ANY MONEY FOR AGRICULTURAL
DISTRICTS THIS IS JUST FOR
GOURMET.
IT STARTED AS DISTRICT.
ONE EIGHTY AND IN THE LAST EIGHT
OR NINE YEARS THE COW PALACE HAS
HOSTED EVENTS ALL THE WAY FROM.
CONCERTS OF COURSE THE FAMOUS
GRAND NATIONAL.
HORSE BOX.
AND CATTLE -- SHOW -- THE ALL OF
THE GUN AT THE FLOWER SHOWS THE
REPTILE.
REPTILE SHOW A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
I SAY WE ENDED BURKE LAY PERHAPS
BUT I FIRST CAME TO THE COW
PALACE IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE AS A VETERAN
OF THE KOREAN WAR IT'S GOT A
HISTORY WHICH IS ON MATCH.
ALBEIT IN ANOTHER DISTRICTS AND
ANY OTHER AG DISTRICT ON THE
STATE YOU LOOK AT THE SENATE
LOUNGE AND YOU SEE ALL THOSE
POSTERS. FOR THE FAIRS FOR THE
EXPOSITION'S.
WHICH ONE WILL BE THE NEXT ONE
TO GO IF THIS LAND GRAB AND THAT
IS NOT A FAST SOLD TERM.
A LAND GRAB IS ALLOWED.
THIS BILL IN ITS PRESENT
CONDITION I WANT TO COMPLIMENT
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE ANALYST OF
THIS BILL.
WASN'T EVEN LEGAL IT VIOLATED
THE LAWS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA A GIVEAWAY.
WITHOUT.
PAYING MARKET VALUE AND I WANNA
SEE THAT IF IT EVER HAPPENED
DALY CITY CONTRIBUTE TO A PAYING
MARKET.
VALUE.
THIS BILL IS BASICALLY A GUN
SHOW BILL.
THE THE MOTIVATION TO SHUT DOWN
THE GUN SHOW.
THE GUN SHOW PEOPLE WILL TAKE
CARE OF THEMSELVES -- USE OF
SUSPECTED FURTHER -- TESTIMONY
YOU WANNA SHOT THE GUN SHOW DOWN.
THERE AND HAVE AN HONEST BAIL
AND NON BILL.
BUT DON'T ENGAGE IN A LAND GRAB
WHICH CHEATS.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA EXCEPT
FOR THOSE WHO LIVE IN DALY CITY
AND THE COUNTY OF SAN MATTEO AND
OF SAN FRANCISCO -- WOULD OF A
U. S. AT WHICH HAS BEEN A PART
OF THOSE STATE SENT TO BE GAGGED
CONSTRUCTION UNDER THE WORKS
PROGRESS ADMINISTRATION.
IN NINETEEN THIRTY SIX AND WAS
DEDICATED IN.
NINETEEN FORTY ONE TAKE ALL OF
THE BILL EXCEPT THE GUN SHOW
PART.
WHICH WAS VETOED LAST YEAR ON A
PERCIPIENT MESSAGE BY THE
HONORABLE EDMUND G. BROWN.
JUNIOR TAKE IT ALL OUT.
DEAL WITH THE GUN SHOW AS YOU
WELL THE GUN SHOW IS GOING TO BE.
HISTORY ON ITS OWN WITH A
RECOMMENDATION FROM COW PALACE
STAB AT THE APRIL MEETING OF THE
BOARD OF THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
NEXT WITNESS MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN FAIRS
ASSOCIATION I LIKE TO MAKE USE
THREE QUICK POINTS MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
FIRST TRUE WHAT SENATOR COP
MENTIONED THIS IS THE AGENDA FOR
THE NEXT CAL PALACE MEETING IT
HAS BEEN THE GEN DIS AS AN
ACTION ITEM FOR THE APPROVAL OF
A STATEMENT OF POLICY TO
DISCONTINUE ALL FUTURE GUN SHOWS
AT THE COW PALACE.
BEGINNING JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY THE DATE IS
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE THAT IS WHEN
THE CONTRACT RUNS OUT FOR THE
CURRENT SITUATION HAD THEY ACTED
ON THIS ANY SOONER.
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN IN BREACH
OF CONTRACT AND THAT WOULD HAVE
CREATED ANOTHER LEGAL ISSUE I
THAT WE NOW SEE HAPPENING AT
ANOTHER DISTRICT ASSOCIATION.
AMENDMENT THREE THIS NOT BEEN
ACCEPTED -- IS ACTUALLY VERY
CRITICAL TO EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE THAT HAS A DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION IN ITS PROPERTY
CURRENT FOOD NAG CODE STATES
THAT IF DISTRICT AGOSTO SOLUTION
PROPERTY IS SOLD.
IT IS TO BE IN PUT IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AGRICULTURE
HELD IN TRUST FOR THAT DISTRICT
AGOSTO SOLUTION. FOR THE
PURPOSES OF RELOCATING THAT
PROPERTY THAT FAIR IF WITHIN
THREE YEARS THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
THIS THE REVENUES FROM THAT SALE
DINNER DISTRIBUTED TO THE REST
OF THE NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA
FAIRS.
THAT WAS DONE SO THAT ONE FAIRS
COULD PLAN AND MOVE AS
COMMUNITIES GROW AND CHANGE BUT
ALSO.
RECOGNIZING THAT IT'S A NETWORK
OF CALIFORNIA FAIRS AND SO IF
ONE IS GOING TO BE SOLD AND NOT
RE INVESTED THAT IS TO THE TO BE
TO THE BENEFIT OF ALL THE REST
OF THE DISTRICT AGOSTO SEE
ASIANS.
WHO HAVE SERIOUS NEEDS -- AND IF
YOU'VE BEEN ON ANY OF THOSE
FAIRGROUND PROPERTY YOU WOULD
KNOW THEY HAVE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS AT A
SIGNIFICANT LEVEL SO WITHOUT THE
ACCEPTANCE OF THAT AMENDMENT
NUMBER.
THREE AT LEAST A CROSS REFERENCE
TO EXISTING LAW EVERY DISTRICT
AGOSTO SOLUTION IN THE STATE AND
COUNTY FAIR FACES SOME JEOPARDY
FROM THIS DISTRICT BILL
[inaudible]
FINALLY.
THERE IS LOCAL CONTROL ON THIS
BOARD IT HAS AN APPOINT A BOOK
APPOINTED BOARD OF NINE MEMBERS
THE FOOD NAG CODE SEC.
THE FOOD AYE CODE STATES THAT
WHEN A DISTRICT AGOSTO SITUATION
OVERLAPS TWO COUNTIES THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE REPRESENTATION
FROM BOTH COUNTIES.
IT EXISTS RIGHT NOW NINE MEMBERS
OF THE BOARD SOME FROM SAN
MATTEO COUNTY SOME FROM THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN RANCISCO.
BY JANUARY THE END OF JANUARY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM WILL HAVE A
MAJORITY OF THE APPOINTED BOARD
MEMBERS.
ON THIS BOARD.
EVERYTHING THAT THIS.
NOW SEEKS TO DO THE TRANSFER
PROPERTY THE LEASING OF PROPERTY
WHICH HAS BEEN NEGOTIATED FOR
YEARS CAN HAPPEN UNDER THE
CURRENT AUTHORITY THE CURRENT --
POWERS INVESTED OR VESTED IN THE
DISTRICT AGOSTO SOLUTION SO
THESE GOALS CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED
THE COMMUNITY GOALS CAN BE
REACHED GOVERNOR NEW SOME WILL
HAVE CONTROL OVER THE BOARD COME
NEXT YEAR.
ALL OF THIS CAN BE RESOLVED
WITHOUT A BILL LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN PLEASE VOTE NO.
TIME LIMIT YOU GUYS HAVE COME
ALL THE WAY HERE SO PLEASE --
PERCY BUT I'D LIKE YOU TO KEEP
IT SHORT IF YOU CAN THANK THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WILL KEEP
IT TO A MINUTE NOW THANK.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KEVIN
PATTERSON I AM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAVE THE COW
PALACE COALITION AND PRODUCER OF
THE DICKENS CHRISTMAS OR AT THE
COW PALACE.
I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
MANY EVENT PRODUCERS AREA
BUSINESSES AND THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ANNUAL VISITORS WHO
BELIEVE IN A BRIGHT FUTURE FOR
THE CAPITALIST.
I CAN SAY WITH PROFESSIONAL
CERTAINTY BUT THE COW PALACE IS
A VITAL AND VIABLE EVENT
FACILITY WHEN EVENTS LIKE THE
GRAND NATIONAL RODEO THE DICKENS
CHRISTMAS FAIR THE GOLDEN GATE
DOG SHOW AND MANY OTHERS.
AND THE HUGE AUDIENCES THAT
ATTEND THEM AND ARRIVE AT THE
COW PALACE THEY RECEIVE ALL THE
PRESENT DAY.
NATIONAL EVENTS SERVICES THEY
REQUIRE FIXING THE ROOMS WOULD
BE GREAT AND THE COW PALACE IS
BUILDING A FUND ITSELF TO DO
THIS BUT IT IS COMPLETELY
FUNCTIONAL ALREADY.
AS WELL AS BEING A UNIQUE AND
IRREPLACEABLE FACILITY.
THAT CAN BE EFFICIENTLY UPGRADED
AT A FRACTION OF THE COST OF
BUILDING ANYTHING NEW ANYWHERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECT THAT SENATOR WIENER
AND HIS CO AUTHORS HAVE AN
INTEREST IN MORE COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT BUT THE COW PALACE
ALREADY SERVES A BROAD CROSS
SECTION OF THE COMMUNITY
REPRESENTED HERE BY OUR%
COALITION AND MANY OTHERS.
WE FEEL STRONGLY THAT THE COW
PALACE SHOULD REMAIN WITHIN THE
STATE FAIRGROUNDS SYSTEM.
THE KALPOE AS GOVERNING BOARD
WILL BE GETTING NEW LOCAL AREA
MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR MYSELF AND OTHER EVENT
PRODUCERS PLEDGE TO WORK WITH
HIS NEWLY ENERGIZED BOARD. TO
PRODUCE EXCITING NEW EVENTS AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS FOR LOCAL
USE THAT ENGAGE THE COMMUNITY
MORE THAN EVER.
AND HOUSING IS MENTIONED BY
MISTER BROWN IS ALREADY
HAPPENING ON ONE THIRD OF THE
AVAILABLE ACREAGE WE ASK THAT
THE COMMITTEE.
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS WRITTEN
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
CAPULETS REPRESENTING -- TODAY
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
GUN OWNERS CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY SO A SPARKLE
OF INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR
SPORTSMAN'S COALITION.
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION -- WE OBVIOUSLY
PARTICIPATE AT THE GUN SHOW WE
HAVE BEEN BEFORE YOU MANY TIMES
I WAS SICK MOST OF MY COMMENTS
FOR THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND
THIS TRIPLE REFERRED MISTER
CHAIRMAN DEPRECIATING THAT.
BUT I WOULD JUST SAY THIS IS A
STATE PROPERTY AND EVENT SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO GO FOR IT THERE
ARE BEEN MANY LAWSUITS.
PENDING OVER BOTH FIRST AND
SECOND AMENDMENT ACCESS FOR ALL
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA THERE IS
A LAWSUIT PENDING -- RIGHT NOW
IT DEL MAR AND THE FEDERAL
COURTS UNDER FIRST AMENDMENT SO.
WE WOULD ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THE
LEGAL IMPLICATIONS THANK YOU ARE
WERE ON THE VERGE OF LOSING SOME
MEMBER SIMON ASKED THE THE
PUBLIC THAT.
THE REST OF PEOPLE THAT ARE --
UP OPPOSED. TO TO TO THIS BILL
TO STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION.
AND YOUR OPPOSITION NO SPEECHES
PLEASE [inaudible]
CHRISSY.
RENO RODEO AND WE ARE BUT THE
PRODUCER OF AFFORDABLE FAMILY
FUN ENTERTAINMENT AT THE GRAND
NATIONAL.
THANK YOU NYPOST.
AND YOUR PATTERSON WITH THE SAVE
THE COW PALACE COALITION AND I'M
OPPOSED.
TRICIA FARBER'S SAVE THE COW
PALACE COALITION AND I OPPOSE.
CAT TAYLOR SAN FRANCISCO
RESIDENT ENTERTAINMENT DIRECTOR
FOR THE EIGHT HUNDRED PERFORMERS
AT THE GREAT DICKENS CHRISTMAS
FAIR FOR TWENTY YEARS OPPOSED
[inaudible]
KIMBALL JACKSON.
OPPOSED THE COW PALACE COALITION.
WHEN THE BOND SAY THE COW PALACE
COALITION OPPOSE?
BETTY SIMMONS FROM VALLEJO I'M
[inaudible]
SORRY.
I AM I AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
IN EVERY WAY I THINK THE COW
PALACE HAS SO MUCH TO OFFER. FOR
THE CIVIC THANK YOU.
ROBERT YOUNG.
SEC THE COW PALACE COALITION.
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS WRITTEN.
WE'LL WOULD OF THEIR POWER THANK
YOU SENATOR DODD.
AND I WILL POST.
JOHN G. SAY THE COW PALACE
COALITION OPPOSED THE BILL AS IT
EXISTS.
MICHELLE SOLOMON BORN IN SAN
FRANCISCO NATIVE DOLLARS OF THE
GOLDEN WEST ADULT GIRL SCOUT
LIFETIME MEMBER.
CAL PALACE COALITION OPPOSED.
GIULIANA GOAL HISTORIAN AND
PERFORMER OPPOSED.
I'M PATRICK ALL FROM MALAYO.
SENATOR DODD I REPRESENT A LOT
OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS OF MYSELF
IN VALLEJO.
WHO OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU?
JEFFREY WEISSMAN OF LOS ANGELES
IN SONOMA COUNTY -- THIS BILL --
NEEDS TO BE AMENDED.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO USE AT
STATION FEMA?
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS AND THE
HOMELESS AFTER CATASTROPHE.
I WASN'T PLANNING TO SPEAK BUT
MY NAME IS MARK COP AND I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE COW PALACE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
IT IS REALLY SAD THAT THE GOOD
BOARD.
THAT HAS WORKED SO HARD AT THE
COW PALACE HAS BEEN GIVEN THE
WRONG IMPRESSION TO ALL OF YOU I
HAVE BEEN ON THE BOARD FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS.
WE HAVE NO.
WE HAVE NO DEBTS BECAUSE OF US
WE HAVE SURPLUSES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FIX OUR ROADS
WE HAVE AN EXCELLENT BOARD WE
WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY WE DO A
LOT OF THINGS FREE.
IF YOU WANT THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE IN HONEST GOOD FAITH
WORK.
WE ARE ONE OF THE GROUPS AND I
RESENT SENATOR WIENERS.
URGING A BUS I HAD TO GET UP TO
TELL YOU HE THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO THE BOARD --
THE LORD.
AND THE COMMITTEE WHAT ARE
WAITING.
SENATOR NIELSEN MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO RAISE THE
ISSUE HERE FOR THE RECORD OF
GERMANUS.
I'M KIND OF FUSSY ABOUT THE
RULES HERE AND THIS IS.
JERMAINE THIS IS OFTEN FOUND IT
BECOMES A PRACTICE BUT THIS IS A
VERY BLATANT EXAMPLE OF GERMANUS
AND I'LL RAISE IT AGAIN ON THE
FLOOR.
I'M GOING TO INQUIRE OF LEAD
COUNSEL FOR THEIR OPINION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS JERMAINE.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE AGRICULTURAL
DISTRICTS YOU KNOW THEY'RE ALL
OVER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THEIR HISTORIC AN ABSOLUTELY
INGRAINED IN THE HISTORY OF THE
STATE.
AND THIS NOW TAPPERS WITH THAT.
THE SACRED POSITION THAT THESE
TAG OF CULTURAL DISTRICTS HOLD.
IN ALL OF OUR DISTRICT ALMOST
[inaudible]
AND THIS IS NOT SOMETHING TO BE
TRIFLED WITH IN MY OPINION.
IT ALSO.
IS FOUNDING PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA Y. SPEC PRIVATE
PROPERTY AND KIND OF SENSITIVE
ABOUT EMINENT DOMAIN.
AND TO ME THIS IS EMINENT DOMAIN
BY ANOTHER MEANS SO [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
HILL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN
THE THANK YOU TO SENATOR COP FOR
BEING HERE TODAY AND I IN
CONVERSING WITH HIM I UNDERSTAND
AND AND AND MRS COP THAT THE THE
THE FAIR.
THE CAL POWERS BORDER THEY HAVE
ABOUT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE IN THE BANK -- TO DO THE
REPAIRS THAT ARE NECESSARY AND
AND I GUESS I'M A IS A SENATOR
WIENER MENTIONED A CO AUTHOR OF
THE LETTER.
THE LEGISLATION AND I'VE GREW UP
AROUND THE COW PALACE IN THE
SINCE IT'S ABOUT SIX YEARS OLDER
THAN I AM -- AND SINCE I'M I
WILL BE RETIRING IN A YEAR AND A
HALF OR TWO YEARS FROM THE THIS
IT MAY BE TIME TO RETIRE THE
CALCULUS AS WELL BUT IT IN
SAYING THAT IT. TO ME THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT HAS BEEN
CRAFTED IN CREATED AROUND THE
CAL POLISH IS THE CHALLENGE AND
THAT'S HISTORICALLY -- HAS BEEN.
SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT FIT INTO
THAT COMMUNITY WHEN IT WAS
CONSTRUCTED IN NINETEEN FORTY
ONE I'M SURE IT DID IT FIT.
INTO OPEN A NEW COMMUNITY THAT
WAS GROWING IN TRYING -- TO TO
DEVELOP BUT WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT THE COMMUNITIES OF STRUGGLE.
IN THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS HAVE
STRUGGLED AND HAD A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME OF OF PROGRESSING
TO THE POINT WHERE THEY CAN --
THEY CAN SUCCEED.
IN THE CRIME ESPECIALLY IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO SIDE IN NOW IN THE
DALY CITY SIDE -- HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING I THINK AS THIS BILL.
AND I APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS.
I THINK THAT WILL TAKE IT IN A
DIRECTION THAT -- THAT I DIDN'T
FOR COMFORTABLE WITH.
BECAUSE WHAT IT DOES IS ALLOW
FOR THAT CONVERSATION TO MOVE
FORWARD.
AS TO WHAT THE COW PALACE YOU
SHOULD BE TO THAT COMMUNITY WHAT
IT SHOULD LOOK LIKE FOR THAT
COMMUNITY.
AND WHAT IT COULD.
WHAT WHAT IT COULD GROW INTO I
DON'T THINK ANYONE WANTS TO
DISCOURAGE OR ELIMINATE -- SOME
OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
OCCURRING AT THE AT THE COW
PALACE BUT THERE MAY BE A WAY OF
DOING THAT.
IN A WAY OF ALSO ALLOWING FOR
OTHER TYPES OF DEVELOPMENT AND
GROWTH WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY.
IF IT'S HOUSING OR IF IT'SSOME
OTHER AMENITIES THAT ARE
NECESSARY FOR STRUGGLE UP FOR
WHAT IS A STRUGGLING COMMUNITY
INTO A THRIVING COMMUNITY.
SO I I THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TAKE THAT
NEXT STEP HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND PERHAPS I MEAN
THE ONE THING ABOUT THE CAL
POLICIES IS NOT THE MOST
ATTRACTIVE BUILDING.
AT EIGHT ANYONE HAS EVER SEEN I
MEAN IT IS IT IS AN EYESORE IN
THE COMMUNITY -- AND PERHAPS
THAT CAN BE RE DONE IN A WAY --
THAT COULD DEVELOP THE COMMUNITY
AND STRENGTH IN THAT COMMUNITY
SO I'LL BE -- THE SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND APPRECIATED MOVING
FORWARD AND HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I THINK A
CRUCIAL. TO THE FUTURE OF DALY
CITY AND IN THE FUTURE OF THAT
SOUTHERN AREA OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO ADDRESS [inaudible]
IT.
YEAH WE HAVE -- GO AHEAD SIR
HUESO.
WERE YOU CAN SAY WELL WE HAVE A
MEMBER THE NEEDS TO LEAVE SO
WE'RE JUST.
GO AHEAD PROCEED.
YES GENERALLY YOU KNOW THIS IS A
REALLY TOUGH ISSUE FOR ME
BECAUSE I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
LOCAL ELECTED SINNERS STRUGGLES
WITH THE COMMUNITY AND AND THERE
ARE SO THERE SEEM TO BE
UNFORTUNATELY SOME CONFLICTS
BETWEEN THE OF THE COMMUNITY
STATE FAIR AND DOES DOES I THINK
NEED. TO BE CORRECTED DAYS THEY
NEED TO BE ROUTED OUT.
BUT I DON'T THINK WE NEED THIS
BILL TO DO THAT I THINK THE LAW
ALREADY ESTABLISHES FOR THE
RELOCATION OF FAIR.
POSES A HARM OR THREAT TO THE
COMMUNITY AND MY HOPE.
IS NOT THAT WE JUST -- UNDUE
AFFAIR BUT IF IF IT NEEDS TO BE
RE RE LOCATED OF IT HE LOOKED
THE FAIR WAS OUR FIRST THE
COMMUNITY.
DEVELOPED AROUND IF THEY DID
FIND A WAY TO PLAN ACCORDINGLY.
THAT THAT'S A THAT'S A FAILURE
ON ON THE LOCAL CITIES THEY THEY
SHOULD HAVE PLANNED A AROUND
THAT.
THE DEVELOPMENT AROUND THE FIRST
HAVE PLANNED ACCORDING. TO A A
RESOURCE THAT'S ALREADY THERE
AND IF THEY DIDN'T DO THAT WELL
THAT'S SOMETHING THEY HAVE TO
DEAL WITH.
BUT IF THE ONLY WAY TO DEAL WITH
THAT IS -- TO TO CLOSE ON THIS
FOR I HOPE THEY IT'S READ
LOCATED.
AND I HOPE THERE'S A REAP A
PROCESS TO RELOCATE WITHIN THAT
COMMUNITY BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
SHAME TO LOSE.
ON IN A RESOURCE LIKE THIS FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE THE WAY I LOOK AT
IT I HAVE WORKED VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR OUR STATE FOR SAN DIEGO
AND IMPERIAL AND IN SACRAMENTO I
HAVE -- SUPPORTED EVENTS IN
SACRAMENTO AND I'VE GOTTEN THEM
TO DO THINGS.
THAT I THINK ARE JUST MARVELOUS --
FOR THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE I
WOULD HATE TO DEPRIVE THE PEOPLE
OF OUR STATE OF THAT RESOURCE.
SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT HAPPENS
AT THESE FAIRS.
ESPECIALLY TO THE BACKBONE WHICH
ARE A LOT OF THE BUSINESSES THAT
TRY FROM THERE NOT ONLY.
THE TWO THEY GO TO THEIR FOR BUT
THEY ALSO SERVE MY FARED SAN
DIEGO AND IMPERIAL AND
SACRAMENTO SO -- THIS IS REALLY
TOUGH ONE OUT ON THE LAY OFF THE
BILL BECAUSE I THINK.
THIS THE ADMINISTRATION OF THIS
FAIRS FIRMLY WITHIN OUR GRASP
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE WHO WE APPOINT THERE.
ARE WE SUPPORTING THE FARES THE
OTHER QUESTION I THINK WE SHOULD
SUPPORT THESE FARES -- WILL GIVE
THEM MORE RESOURCES I WOULD
SUPPORT THAT -- I HAVE WORK TO
RAISE MONEY FOR THE FAIRS.
AND CREATE PROGRAM MEAN AND IF
YOU'LL GIVE THEM BETTER OPTIONS
I KNOW THEY WILL EXERCISE AND
THEY'LL BRING TO YOUR COMMUNITY
THINGS THAT ARE BETTER FOR THE
COMMUNITY OF COURSE THEY WILL.
IT'S ALL INCUMBENT ON ON ON THE
MEMBERS THAT WE APPOINT TO THE
BOARD AND IT LOOKS LIKE.
THEY NEED OUR HELP AND I THINK
THAT'S IT SHOULD BE THE APPROACH
OF TAKES CENTER WAY THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM CENTER
HILL THAT ARE GALGIANI.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
QUESTION.
UNDER THIS BILL UNDER THIS
FRAMEWORK WOULD ALLOW FOR D. G.
S. AND THE CURRENT BOARD WHOM
EVER TO BE ABLE.
TO COME UP WITH THE WAY THAT THE
COW PALACE COULD USE A SECTION
OF THE PROPERTY AND THEN.
OTHER SECTIONS OF THE PROPERTY
BE USED FOR A HIGHER USE THAT
THE COMMUNITY WOULD GET BEHIND.
YES I SENATOR THIS BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU AGAIN THE
CHAIR AND HIS COMMITTEE.
GIVES COMPLETE FLEXIBILITY TGS
COULD DECIDE WE'RE NOT SELLING
ANYTHING AND WE'RE KEEPING THE
STATUS QUO OR WE'RE GOING TO
SELL A PORTION OF THE LAND WAR
WHICH IS GOING TO CHANGE HOW WE
MANAGE.
THE LAND AND KEEP THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS THE COMPLETE ALL THIS
DOES IS AUTHORIZED AND REQUIRED
DISCUSSION BUT IT DOESN'T
REQUIRE ANY PARTICULAR RESULT.
DUNCAN IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT IN ANY WAY DICTATE THE
REMOVAL OF THE CAL PALACE THIS
BILL SAYS NOTHING ABOUT WHETHER
THE CAL PALACE.
IS REMOVED OUT WILL BE A
DECISION A TGS CAN MAKE OR THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY CAN MAKE UP IT
SOLD.
I I HAVE A FURTHER QUESTION A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION TO THAT I
DON'T LIKE GIVING THAT MUCH
AUTHORITY FROM THE LEGISLATURE
AINGE'S DELEGATING THAT TO D. G.
S. I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
AND I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT
THIS BILL.
IF PASSED -- THE STAGE THAT IT
SETS FOR SOMETHING ELSE MAYBE
NEXT TIME IT'S MY FAIR AND ONE
OF MY DISTRICTS -- SO WOULD YOU
CONSIDER AN AMENDMENT TO IT IF
THIS BILL MOVES TO THAT POINT
AND D. G. S. THEN HAS THE
ABILITY TO LOOK AT THIS MAKE
THIS DECISION.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO TAKE AN
AMENDMENT THAT REQUIRES THAT
NOTHING CAN BE SOLD UNLESS THE
LEGISLATURE AT A LATER TIME THEN
IT PROVES THAT SALE WHETHER
THAT'S LANGUAGE TAKEN IN A
FUTURE BUDGET FOR WHETHER IT'S A
SEPARATE BILL DOWN THE ROAD.
I'D BE OPEN TO THAT CONVERSATION
CENTER I'M NOT I CAN'T AGREED
ABOUT YOU KNOW ON THE FLY.
TODAY ABOUT THIS BILL IS A WORK
IN PROGRESS WE KNOW THAT AND IT
SPARKED A CONVERSATION.
AND AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR IT TO MOVE FORWARD.
WITHOUT THIS BILL THAT NOW
THEY'RE CANCELING THE GUN SHOWS.
WHAT IT TOOK THAT BECAUSE OF
THIS BILL?
FINALLY THERE LISTENING AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE WANT THIS BILL TO
MOVE FORWARD AND HE'S.
LEAVING [inaudible] FOR PLEASE
[inaudible]
CENTER GLAZER [inaudible]
YEAH.
JUST AYE I DIDN'T HEAR THE
BEGINNING OF THE CENTERS
PRESENTATION DID HE ACCEPT ALL
THE AMENDMENT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS INCLUDING THEM IN.
THREE IT DID NOT ALL BUT TWO AND
THREE ALL RIGHT.
WELL FOR MEI MEAN IN SOME WAYS
THIS IS A DISTRICT ISSUE AND
RESPECT THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE AREA -- AND THEIR
SENSITIVITY TO THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY.
ON THE OTHER HAND I DO THINK
THAT WE DO HAVE SOME STATE
RESPONSIBILITY HERE IN THIS
MATTER I DO.
AGREE WITH SENATOR GALGIANI IS --
AMENDMENT THAT -- IT WE SHOULD
HAVE SOME BECAUSE SOME IT --
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS IT SHOULD BE
A COMPLETE APPLICATION -- TO D.
G. S. SO I I'M WILLING TO MOVE
THE BILL FOR TODAY ALTHOUGH
THESE QUESTIONS REMAIN AND I
HOPE THAT WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR -- WE CAN CLEAR THEM UP
BEFORE I THE MATTER GETS THE
FLOOR SO THAT THAT'S THAT'S MY
FEELING -- NINE FORGIVE ME ALL I
WAS ALSO ON LATER THIS SO WAS
THIS ISSUE DISCUSSED IN OF
SOCIAL WHICH GIVE ME A SHORT
ANSWER.
WAS THIS EVER LOOKED UPON BY --
BY COUNSEL AS WHETHER THIS WOULD
BE A GIFT OF PUBLIC FUNDS
[inaudible]
BOB.
I'M NOT SURE IT HAS BEEN WITH
THE AMENDMENTS THAT HE'S
ACCEPTED THAT I ASKED NEW EXCEPT
IT'S NOT DOING THAT ANYMORE.
BUT IS INSTEAD OF TO TRY TO
CAUSE A MEMBER LEFT BUT NO IT'S
NOT THIS ALL IS SIMPLY.
A IT AUTHORIZES THE SALE.
PURSUANT TO A NEGOTIATION. FOR
WORK OR DIGEST COULD DECIDE NOT
TO SELL.
THE ALL IT DOES SO THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT THE AMENDMENT IS THE BILL.
TO SIMPLY AUTHORIZES THE SALE.
OR NOT WHAT AUTHORIZES THE AND
THEY CAN DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
TO SELL.
AT MARKET RATE.
OUR OUR YES.
THE MEMBER EVEN GOES FURTHER IN
THE BEST IF IF THEY DETERMINE
ITS THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
STATE PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISH TO
COMMENT -- I I YOU KNOW JUST FOR
THE PUBLIC EVERYTHING -- THE
SENATOR CAME TO MY OFFICE.
I WAS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND
BASICALY THE REASON WHY I WAS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL WAS IT WAS A
GIFT IN MY VIEW THE WAY THE BILL
WAS PRESENTED.
HE TOOK WE PRESENTED THEM IT'S
TO A AND THE ONCE THE CONCERNED
ME THE MOST HE ACCEPTED -- THE
OTHER AMENDMENTS THAT HE IS NOT
ACCEPTED WILL BE ADDRESSED IN
PUBLIC SAFETY I THINK THAT'S
APPROPRIATE.
EXCUSE AT THOSE PUBLIC SAFETY
WAS GOING TO NEXT.
IT IS REPORTED STRIPPERS FOR IT
YET.
SO SO AT ANY RATE -- THAT'S WHY --
YOU KNOW.
THAT'S WHY I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY.
SO WITH THAT CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
FILE ITEM WHAT SORRY WE HAVE
DOCTOR -- WANTED TO BUT WAS VERY
BRIEFLY WHEN I WITH RESPECT TO
CENTER GLAZERS COMING WITH THE
OTHER TWO AMENDMENTS I ACTUALLY
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM.
WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS AT ALL BUT
IF IT WERE TALKING ABOUT
PROBABLY A SIGNIFICANT SUM OF
MONEY -- AND I TO ME IT IT
DOESN'T MATTER FOR PREPAY.
INTO THE GENERAL FUND OR STAYS
WITH THE FAIRS BUT THAT'S A
DECISION THAT I THINK.
NEEDS TO BE. FIVE FIVE MADE AND
I DON'T I DON'T CARE WHICH WAY
THAT THAT FALLS BUT I THINK THAT
THAT DOESN'T BILLION A BIGGER
ISSUE BECAUSE IT WILL BE ABLE.
TO TOUCH A LARGE SUM OF MONEY
AND IN TERMS OF THE
REIMBURSEMENT OF THE OF THESE
YES FOR ANY EXPENSES -- I HAVE
NO PROBLEM WITH THAT EITHER --
ANY DEAL WILL INCORPORATE THAT
BUT IF THAT GOES INTO THE BILL I
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT
BUT WE HAD DECIDED THAT WE WOULD
TAKE THOSE BOTH UP AND
APPROPRIATIONS INSTEAD OF HERE.
BUT I'M NOT OBJECTING TO EITHER --
ONE AND THEN I JUST TO BE A FEW
THINGS THAT WERE SAID -- TO
CENTER HUESO THE FAIR WAS YOUR
FIRST KNOW THE PAIR WASN'T HERE
FIRST THE DALY CITY WAS THERE.
FIRST AND SO THIS IS AN ISSUE
THEY HAVE STRUGGLED WITH FOR A
LONG TIME -- THESE LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND LEADERS SUPPORT
THIS BILL THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON AROUND THERE -- AND THEY'RE
ASKING US. TO DO THIS AND
THEY'RE ASKING US FOR MORE OF A
SAY IN WHAT HAPPENS -- AT THE
COW PALACE -- YOU KNOW AS I JUST
MENTIONED -- THE FACT THAT AFTER
ALL THESE DECADES THEY REFUSE TO
GET RID OF HIS GUN SHOWS BUT
EVERYONE MONEY ARE GONE -- AND
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED IN THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THEY JUST
IGNORED IT.
BIG NOR IT AND NOW THEY'RE
CLAIMING -- WE'RE GETTING RID OF
THE GUN SHOWS BECAUSE OF THIS
BILL AND SOMETIMES IT'S ASKING
FOR THIS BILL TO MOVE FORWARD SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE.
OUR CONVERSATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK.
FOR AND SHE JUST FOR THE JUST
FOR THE RECORD HERE THIS IS
GOING TO PUBLIC SAFETY NEXT I DO
NOT THINK THAT THE DOES TO
AMENDMENTS REQUIRE THE AUTHORITY
REIMBURSE.
TGS FOR ANY COST OR EXPENSE
INCURRED IN THE DISPOSITION.
IN A MEMBER THREE REQUIRE THE
NET PROCEEDS OF AN ANYBODY --
THE THE GO TO THE THE FEAR AN
EXPOSITION FINDER THE GENERAL
FUND -- THOSE WILL BE HANDLED IN
APPROPRIATIONS -- SO I JUST I I
JUST I SAID SOMETHING EARLIER
THAT MAY HAVE MADE SOMEBODY
BELIEVE THAT THOSE WERE GOING TO
NECESSARILY BE HEARD IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE.
THEY WILL MOST DEFINITELY BE
HEARD [inaudible]
SORRY [inaudible]
WHAT OKAY?
WHEN YOU'RE DONE IF I GET?
PLEASE SET FORTINO AND AS FAR AS
I I KNOW THE PEOPLE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT THINGS BEING HANDLED AND
APPROPRIATIONS I'VE BEEN
COMMITTED.
ANYTHING.
THE SERVER BODY KNOWS THERE'S NO.
THE PROBE THERE'S NO DEAL WITH
APPROPRIATIONS YET OTHER THAN
IT'S GOING TO IF IT GETS OUT OF
THE NEXT COMMITTEE IT'S GOING TO
COME TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AND WILL FURTHER CONVERSATION
BUT THERE THERE ARE NO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED.
OR INTRODUCED TO SERVE IN THAT
IF A FIVE PLY DAD I DID I DIDN'T
MEAN TO IMPLY THAT BASICALLY
[inaudible]
WHATEVER AMENDMENTS.
ARE GOING TO BE THE IF IF THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE GONNA BE HEARD
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HEARD IN
APPROPRIATIONS.
THERE ARE ENOUGH.
RECORDS CLICK HERE [inaudible]
CRYSTAL RIGHT.
OKAY CAN WE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
FILE ITEM FOR SB TWO EIGHT ONE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY.
DODD.
DODD AYE WILK.
WILK NO ALLEN [inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible] FOR JESS.
FOR JUST NOW BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL I WEST SO [inaudible]
JONES.
JONES NO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
WIENER HI WIENER I SEVEN TO FOUR
THE BILL HAS -- SEVEN SEVEN TO
FOUR WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
OKAY.
SO MEMBERS NEED TO BE CALLED IF
THEY'RE MISSING AND THEN.
OPEN THE ROLE NOW BUT MEMBERS
AND WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE
NOW BUT WE NEED WE WERE CALLING
ABSENT MEMBERS.
DON'T DO IT NOW.
THEY WERE GONNA GO THROUGH THE
ROLE RIGHT NOW BUT THEY WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN -- FOR FIVE
MINUTES AFTER -- WE THE FIRST
TIME WE GO THROUGH THE ROLE.
STARTING FROM THE TOP CONSENT.
ABSENT MEMBERS -- IT THE VOTES
LEVIN ZERO CONSENT CALENDAR
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
[inaudible] FOR JESS.
OR JUST AYE GLAZER.
LATER I A WEST SO.
WEST SO I WIENER.
WIENER HI. FIFTEEN ZERO THERE'S
ONE FIFTEEN ZERO THE BILL. ZERO
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN.
IN THIS.
I FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TO ALLEN.
FILE ITEM TO SP ONE SIXTY MOTION
IS.
DO PASSED THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT BEAU IS NINETY ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
[inaudible] TO FOR JESS.
THIS IS TWO THIRDS OF THE FILE
ITEM TO SP. ONE SIXTY FOR JUST I
AND ALLEN.
NO ALLEN OKAY [inaudible]
CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO I'D.
CHAIRS IN AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER I FIFTEEN ZERO THAT OUT
OF PUTTING IT -- FIFTEEN ZERO
WILL STILL HOLD THE ROLE OF FOR
ALAN.
FILE ITEM THREE SB TWO THIRTY
SEVEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VO IS SIX TWO ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
GORGEOUS.
GORGEOUS I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER.
GLAZER I'D WEST SO.
WHY SO I JONES?
JONES I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER.
WIENER AYE GALGIANI AYE.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN VOTES -- WE
WILL -- HOLD ROLE OPEN.
FILE ITEM FOR SB TWO EIGHTY ONE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
CHIANG.
OUR WEST SO [inaudible]
RUBIO -- I RECORDED NIELSEN
[inaudible]
NELSON NELSON NOW. 747-4 YEAH
WILL HOLD THE ROLL UP AND WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD.
FILE ITEM EIGHT SB FIVE FIVE
THREE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE IS FORTY TWO CHAIR VOTING
NO.
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BOARD YES. FOR JUST AYE BRADFORD
[inaudible]
CHIANG.
CHIANG I DOUBT GLAZER
[inaudible]
WESSEL.
NIELSEN ALL RIGHT.
NIELSEN I PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER NOW [inaudible] 277-23
WILL HOLD THAT -- ROLE OPEN.
FILE ITEM NINE AS THE FIVE FIVE
EIGHT MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BEAU IS NINE ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN. FOR JESS.
BUT FIVE EIGHT FIVE FOR JUST I
CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER I THAT IS FIFTEEN ZERO
FIFTEEN ZERO HOLD ROLE
[inaudible]
OPEN.
FILE ITEM TWELVE SB SIX SEVENTY
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BOTH TEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible] FIVE FOR
JUST I CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE WEST SO [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER I EIGHTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN
ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLE BUT FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN SB SEVEN ONE SEVEN
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE IS.
EIGHT ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
AGES I CHIANG CHIANG AYE GLAZER
GLAZER AYE WEST SO.
WHY SO I'D NIELSEN?
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE FIFTEEN ZERO HOLD
FIFTEEN ZERO HOLD ROLE OPEN. ONE
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SB SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA.
GORGEOUS FIVE FOR JUST AYE
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE WEST SO WHY SO I
JONES.
JONES I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER AYE [inaudible]
SO THAT. FIFTEEN ZERO ZERO ZERO
HOLD ROLL UP AND WE'RE GONNA
HOLD ROLL UP FOR FIVE MINUTES
[inaudible]
ACTION [inaudible]
DID [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY HOUSING IS.
ALLEN.
IS OUT.
YEAH ALLEN -- REVIEWS ON THE WAY
BACK.
ARCHULETA AND FOR MY TALENT Và
DOWNSTAIRS I SUSPECT
.
IT'S BEEN CRAZY SO GONE IT'S
CRAZY TO DO THE ROAD KILL THING
RIGHT NOW -- WE'RE YEAH.
YEAH YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
HE'S PRESENTING ARENA
[inaudible]
YEAH.
FILE ITEM TO SB ONE SIXTY MOTION
IS DO PASS THROUGH CORPORATIONS
COMMITTEE KERN VOTE FIFTEEN ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
THIS IS THIS IS -- HI YES.
ALLEN I SIXTEEN ZERO SOUTH.
GO BACK [inaudible]
TO OKAY NUMBER.
FILE ITEM THREE SB TWO THIRTY
SEVEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE IS THIRTEEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
HI ALAN HI ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I RUBIO.
SO FIFTEEN ZERO THAT'S OUT.
DONALD OPEN FOR THE THE YEAH
WE'RE TO HOLD OPEN. FOR FOR A
SEVEN RUBIO.
FILE CAN WE GET A CALL IN --
STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT SHE IS
COMING BACK POLICE.
FILE ITEM FOR SB TWO EIGHTY ONE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
pFEMALE ICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA.
SB TWO EIGHT ONE OUR WINNER
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA I ARCH LETTER I CHIANG
WEST SO [inaudible]
RUBIO. NINE TO FOUR WITH RUBIO
HOLDING IT OPEN FOR YOU.
THANK BILLS NINE TO FOUR WITH
RUBIO -- NOT VOTING YET -- WE'RE
HOLD THE ROLE FOR HER.
AS A COURTESY.
FILE ITEM EIGHT SB FIVE FIVE
THREE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN TWO THREE
CHAIR VOTING NO.
ALLEN AB MEMBERS ALLEN
[inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
WORK GLAZER [inaudible]
WEST SO [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I TO KNOW [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible] SIX SIX THE
BILL FOR SIX THE FOR IT FAILS
BUT I HAVE GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION [inaudible]
VERY KIND.
PERCENT GOOD OLD CENTER WILL
[inaudible]
CAN [inaudible]
NEXT.
FILE ITEM NINE SB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT ROE IS FIFTEEN IS THEIR
APPS MEMBER ALLEY.
ALLEN I SIXTEEN BILLS OUT
SIXTEEN OO.
FILE ITEM TWELVE SB SIX SEVENTY
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERN
ABOUT FIFTEEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBER
ALLEN.
ALLEN ICE BILLS OUT SIX NO.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AS BE SEVEN
ONE SEVEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE FIFTEEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBER ALLEN.
ALLEN. SIXTEEN ZERO FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN SB SEVEN FOUR EIGHT
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE FIFTEEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBER
ALLEN OF ABSENT MEMBER ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA EYES AT SOUTH SKILLS
OUT.
SIXTEEN ZERO FINANCES WITH THEM
[inaudible]
THE ROLE.
FILE ITEM THREE SB TWO THIRTY
SEVEN MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
CORPORATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS.
FIFTEEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBER RUBIO.
SB TWO THIRTY SEVEN HERTZBERG.
RUBIO HI SIXTEEN ZERO THAT
SIXTEEN ZERO THAT IS OUT.
FILE ITEM FOR SB TWO EIGHT ONE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS NINE TO FOUR
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO
[inaudible]
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
WEST SO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO I IT'S TEND TO FOR THAT
BILLS OUT TEND.
TO FOR BY -- ONE MORE SET ARE
THE GIVE ONE MORE -- OR MAYBE
YOU'RE.
THE STATE A LOT OF VERY GOOD
[inaudible]
YES.
WITH THE SCORE.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
YEAH YOU'RE GOING.
TO BACK INCLUDES THE BUSINESS
BEFORE THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTEE IN THIS
MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED